[Musique]
Thomas Danson Bourg, bonsoir. Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ? Mais
d'abord, merci pour l'invitation. fait
plaisir d'être là dans ce fauteuil
légendaire et euh j'ai j'ai la chance
d'être dans un couple heureux depuis 27
ans avec Valérie après avoir été un
célibataire dans un célibat défensif qui
ne croyait pas à l'engagement. J'ai la
chance d'être le papa joyeux de trois
jeunes adultes aujourd'hui, trois jeunes
filles alors que je ne pensais pas un
instant avoir des enfants quand j'avais
30 35 ans. Et tout ça vient du fait que
j'enseigne depuis plus de 30 ans une
approche de connaissance de soi
permettant de mettre le meilleur de soi
au service de tous. Vous faisiez quoi
avant ? J'étais avocat. J'étais avocat
dans l'intention d'aider les gens à
traverser les conflits. J'avais repéré
que bien qu'ayant grandi dans une
famille aimante avec de bons parents
présents, attentifs, j'ai eu cette
chance, je reconnais famille nombreuses,
on était cinq enfants. Ben, il y avait
des conflits, des tensions, la porte qui
claque, la bouderie qui s'installe 2h, 2
jours, 2 mois. J'étais sensible à ces
climats. Peut-être qu'aujourd'hui, on
dirait hyper sensible, je sais pas. Mais
je me demandais mais qu'est-ce qui fait
que les humains sont capables de tant de
prévenance, de générosité, d'attention
la plupart du temps, mais aussi
incapable d'éviter le jugement qui
tranche. Tac ! La croyance qui m'étonne,
tu es comme ça, tu changeras pas. Et
eux, ils sont comme ça, ils changeront
pas. La pensée binaire soit ceci, soit
cela qui déchire et qui divise et puis
derrière ça, les il faut, tu dois, c'est
comme ça, c'est mon rôle, c'est ton rôle
qui plombe. À l'époque, je n'avais
aucune idée de ces cinq de ces quatre
mécanismes violents en fond de
contrainte. Je les découvrirai beaucoup
plus tard en pratiquant la communication
non violente dont nous parlerons. Mais
effectivement, je me suis dit peut-être
je me suis dit euh les êtres humains
sont malillés pour traverser les
conflits, les tensions. Moi, j'ai envie
d'aider à faire ça. Et à l'époque, j'ai
encore aucune idée de la psychothérapie.
Je deviens donc avocat et de cit mon
premier métier, être avocat pour aider
les gens à traverser les conflits. Quel
type de droit ? Droits des affaires.
Droits des affaires plutôt. Oui, droit
des affaires. J'ai quand même on fait un
stage avec pas mal d'affaires pénales.
Ça m'a beaucoup plu mais avant de se
faire un nom dans les affaires pénales,
il faut 10 à 15 ans et j'avais pas cette
patience. Donc je suis entré dans les
affaires, dans le droit des
affaires, les beau les marques, les
enseignes, le commerce quoi. Mais donc
beaucoup de conflits et là j'ai vu que
le conflit la plupart du temps a trit à
des malentendus. Et si j'observe le
malentendu d'un peu plus brè, le
malentendu est un combiné de mal exprimé
et de mal écouter. Une personne n'a pas
exprimé clairement ce qu'elle aimerait,
ce qu'elle souhaiterait, ce qui à ses
yeux rendrait la situation plus
agréable. Cette personne a
malheureusement exprimé des jugements,
des critiques, des reproches, des
insultes ou des injures. Pas
inévitablement l'interlocuteur, il a
entendu les jugements, les critiques,
les reproches et les insures. Il n'a pas
entendu des propositions pour que la
situation soit plus agréable. Donc
l'interlocuteur s'est enfui en claquant
la porte ou a répondu paf, sur le même
ton mal exprimé. mal écouté, mal entendu
et j'ai réalisé que comme avocat, je
mettais beaucoup d'énergie à tenter de
monter des solutions juridiques pour des
enjeux qui était largement, pas
uniquement, des enjeux de connaissance
de soi, des enjeux d'empathie pour cet
humain-là et de compréhension de ce qui
se passe à l'intérieur, des enjeux
d'empathie pour cet humainlà en face et
de compréhension de ce qui se passe chez
l'autre et des enjeux donc
d'intelligence émotionnelle. Et
figurez-vous que dans ma formation
d'avocat, j'ai pas reçu un cours de
connaissance de soi, pas un cours
d'empathie pour soi, pas un cours
d'écoute de l'autre, pas un cours
d'écoute de l'autre. C'est quand même
dingue. Alors qu'un avocat est supposé
donner des conseils et je n'ai pas reçu
un cours d'intelligence émotionnelle.
Vos émotions, on s'en fout. On va vous
trouver une bonne solution juridique et
tout ira bien comme ça. C'est pathétique
le niveau de la formation. C'est pas
comme ça qu'on règle un divorce, une
adoption d'enfant, une séparation de
terrain, une sortie d'indivision entre
indivisaire, une succession délicate.
Mon dieu, les enjeux émotionnels sont
partout et c'est ça l'essence du vivre
ensemble. Et donc je me suis dit, je
suis pas au bon endroit. Moi, j'ai envie
d'aider les humains à retrouver des
relations heureuses, joyeuses et fluides
et fluides. L'outil du droit peut être
un outil mais c'est pas ça le vrai
enjeu. Et donc j'ai eu envie de faire
autre chose.
Bienvenue Thomas. Merci.
Aujourd'hui, on va parler de choses
difficiles, peut-être d'adhérence, de
conflit, de peut-être de diplomatie. Ah,
parce que c'est une diplomatie de tous
les jours la vie.
Clairement. Clairement, ça demande de
privilégier la qualité des liens.
Malheureusement, nos systèmes éducatifs
depuis la scolarité toute petite nous
invite à faire faire, être le meilleur,
être en compétition, gagner, avoir la
meilleure place. Et nous sommes dans une
précipitation qui oublie la qualité
d'être. Soi, être avec les autres, être
avec la vie. Et c'est ça qui permet de
privilégier le lien plutôt que le
résultat. Beaucoup de nos difficultés,
de nos tensions aujourd'hui viennent
qu'on est préoccupé. Résultat. Tu as
fait tes devoirs, tu as pris ta douche,
tu as brossé tes dents, tu as mis ton
pyjama, tu es prêt pour demain, tu vas
passer ton bac, on est dans les choses à
faire. Et quand est-ce qu'on rêve ?
Quand est-ce qu'on s'enchante ? Quand ce
qu'on soupaèse ce qu'on aime, ce qu'on
aime pas, quand ce qu'on accueille les
dépis comme les enchantements, il y a
peu de place pour la qualité d'être dans
nos habitudes. Il est vraiment temps
qu'on réapprenne ça. Alors, avant de
commencer dans le dur, je vais je vais
poser quelques questions pour comprendre
l'homme. Oui. Tu crois en Dieu ? Ah,
j'ai envie de immédiatement de répondre
comme Jung répondait. On sait la
dimension spirituelle du travail de
Jung. évidemment une clé et j'ai adoré
cette interview dans lesquelles il
répond non et à cette question et le
journaliste comment vous vous faites un
travail spirituel et il répond avec un
petit sourire très fin et ses petites
lunettes qui ressemblent d'ailleurs un
peu aux miennes. Il dit non je ne crois
pas en Dieu
le I know I know him dit-il l'interview
en anglais. Je veux dire que par là que
j'ai grandi dans une famille catholique
très pratiquante et que ça m'a donné
certainement l'ouverture à la dimension
transcendant au sacré à une présence
infinie au-delà de nous et je remercie
cette tradition pour ça. Évidemment que
j'adhère pleinement à la puissance du
message christique sans aucun doute
message d'amour et et d'accueil
inconditionnel des uns des autres et
cependant je me suis senti à l'étroit
dans la pratique religieuse que j'ai
maintenu longtemps bien plus longtemps
que mes amis jusqu'à 33 3 34 ans.
maintenu cette pratique et puis j'ai eu
besoin de sentir une enfin de nourrir en
moi une aspiration spirituelle au-delà.
Je suis plein de respect pour les
Belgiens qui trouvent dans la pratique
religieuse une occasion d'être de plus
en plus joyeux et de plus en plus
généreux et c'est pas forcément ce que
je vois. Ton poète préféré et je
voudrais que tu m'en parles.
Bon, il y en a certainement beaucoup
mais tu dis que le matin tu te lèves
avec la poésie, c'est ça ? pas
régulièrement, je lis la poésie ou le
soir avant de m'endormir. Oui, comme
aussi des messages de sagesse pour me
recentrer et le premier qui me vient à
l'esprit, c'est Walt Whitman, un poète
américain que j'ai découvert grâce au
film Les poètes disparus qui est sorti,
je sais plus 30 ans, je pense, au moins
ce film. Et je connaissais pas ce poète
américain et franchement j'ai été
extrêmement touché par la richesse, la
finesse, l'amour de la terre, de la
nature, des odeurs. Moi, je vis dans la
forêt en Arden belge. Je je je suis
belge, je vis en Belgique et mon père
était forestier, il adorait les arts. Il
m'a transmis cet amour là. Et donc un
poète qui sait célébrer la beauté de la
vie, la beauté de de l'enchantement,
d'être dehors, de de se de se
rencontrer. Voilà, c'est certainement le
premier poète auquel je pense et je me
ressource souvent le relisant.
Tu veux nous faire un verre ?
[Musique]
Ah mon dieu, c'est c'est en plus en
anglais, hein. Donc arrête de jurer,
s'il te plaît.
Euh il y a un je ne le connais pas bien
comme ça, mais c'est c'est un poème qui
s'appelle me life. Oh moi, oh ma vie. Et
c'est c'est un un hommage à au fait que
il y a plein de désappointements dans la
vie. les trains remplis de gens
incroyants et
cetera. Quel ce que je comment est-ce
que je peux vivre à travers tout ça ? Et
la réponse dans le poème
est quelle est ma contribution possible
?
Ça c'est la réponse. Donc devant ce
désarroi devant la vie, la réponse est
que la vie existe. Elle demeure à
travers ses intempéries et le grand
spectacle de la vie continue et tu peux
y apporter ta contribution. Ça je trouve
ça extrêmement précieux par les temps
que nous courons aujourd'hui de réaliser
chacun peut apporter une contribution à
ce chamboulement invraisemblable dans
lequel nous sommes. Je vois qu'on a le
même accent donc c'est absolument
parfait. Un accent belge, c'est ça
? Arrête hein. Bon on va parler de
choses un peu plus dures. Est-ce que tu
as suivi un petit peu l'actualité en
France ces temps-ci ? Est-ce que tu as
vu que il y a des gens qui des jeunes
qui attaquent des gens au couteau, qui a
qui a des morts poignardé ? Il y a des
gamins qui débarquent, il y a un gamin
qui a débarqué dans son collège et qui a
qui a qui a poignardé d'une façon
hystérique une pauvre gamine, une
frénésie de violence.
Toi en tant que psychologue, comment tu
et en tant qu'homme, comment tu analyses
ça
? Je répondrai comme un journaliste a
répondu au Québec il y a des années pour
un crime semblable, il s'agit d'un
affreux manque de vocabulaire.
C'est un tragique manque de capacité à
identifier un et formuler deux ce qui se
passe à l'intérieur de soi. Quand j'ai
pas les mots pour dire que je me sens
triste, déçu, découragé, seul,
impuissant, en rage, quand j'ai pas les
mots pour identifier que ces sentiments,
ça renseignent mon besoin
d'appartenance, de reconnaissance, de
trouver ma place, de comprendre ce qui
se passe, d'être compris, mon besoin de
solidarité, de partage, de perspective,
de sens et d'amour, les besoins
fondamentaux des humains. Quand je n'ai
pas ce discernement ni la capacité à
formuler ce qui se passe en moi. Les
frustrations s'accumulent, s'accumulent,
s'accumulent et ça fait cocotte minute
et tôt tout tard, ça pète. Et c'est ça
qui arrive malheureusement par défaut de
d'occasion de développer un vocabulaire
de la vie intérieure permettant de se
connaître. La connaissance de soi est un
enjeu de santé publique. Tu as tu as lu
son ses 13 pages de mail qu'il a envoyé
à tout le monde ou pas ? Ça, j'ai pas
lu. J'ai entendu qu'il l'avait fait. Je
je serais bien sûr intéressé à le lire,
mais j'ai pas eu l'occasion de lire ça.
Comment tu analyses cette société
occidentale où ces jeunes commencent
à non pas à verbaliser leur souffrance
mais à passer à l'acte ? Est-ce que tu
vois une corrélation entre le
confinement, le côté prédateur du
capitalisme, le côté on a plus vraiment
de prof, on a plus vraiment de figure
d'autorité. Cette course, cette
cavalerie, qu'est-ce que toi tu analyses
sur notre jeunesse et sur ses
perspectives ? Un immense désarroi
devant la perte de sens. Le capitalisme
a créé une société extrêmement
matérielle. Nous avons créé une laïcité
étouffante dans laquelle il n'y a plus
de place pour la vie intérieure et la
perspective de la transcendance d'un
au-delà. Quel que soit les mots de façon
très ouverte et non confentionnelle, ça
n'existe plus. On n'en parle pas. Et les
êtres l'être profond que nous sommes
chacun ne peut pas se contenter de
bouffer du McDo et de scroller
indéfiniment sur internet. C'est pas ça
le sens de la vie. Or, jusqu'ici, ben
beaucoup de jeunes ne savent pas qu'il y
a un sens de la vie plus profond et donc
ils vivent dans le dépit d'une vie qui
n'a aucun sens et donc ça fait des
explosions comme celle-là. J'ai j'ai
beaucoup côtoyé ça parce que quand j'ai
senti que mon métier de juriste ne me
plaisait plus, je voulais trouver du
sens à ma vie et j'ai l'occasion de
m'occuper en bénévolat à côté de mon
métier de jurisme d'une association pour
des jeunes dit de la rue, des jeunes
dans les gagnes de rue, dans la
consommation de drogue, dans le la
petite délinquence et cetera. pendant 10
ans. C'était une expérience pivot pour
réaliser que je voulais m'occuper
d'humain et aider les humains à trouver
du sens dans la vie. Mais ça m'a permis
également de travailler la compréhension
de cette mécanique de la violence que je
viendrai résumer qui est un manque de
discernement, conscience et de
vocabulaire pour comprendre cet humain
ça. Cet humainlà. Et l'immense bénéfice
qu'il y a puisque j'enseigne maintenant
une approche de connaissance de soi,
c'est plus je comprends l'humain qui est
là dedans, plus j'ai des clés pour
comprendre l'humain qui est là devant.
Et donc l'empathie que je développe pour
moi me sert à avoir de l'empathie pour
l'autre. Mais comment avoir de
l'empathie pour celui qui est là si j'en
ai aucune pour celui qui est ici ? Et ça
c'est vraiment l'enjeu. Nous devrions
apprendre ce que c'est que
l'empathie. Tourner vers soi
auto-empathie et tourner vers l'autre
depuis la maternelle. Ça devrait être la
clé du vivre ensemble. Comment tu
analyses la réponse étatique
? En France, on va installer des
portillons à l'entrée des écoles.
Peut-être que la prochaine étape, c'est
des panic room blindés et des policiers
armés.
Comment tu analyses la communication
politique ? Comment tu analyses les
répercussions de leur technique de
nudge, de terraformation sociétale de
l'individu par X ou Y ne thérapie ou
approche, neuromarketing, neurochin.
Comment comment tu percevras notre
classe occidentale politique et leur
façon de
communiquer, de s'agresser verbalement,
d'infuser ce venin de la communication
politique ? Est-ce que toi tu peux nous
donner not ton avis de psychologue sur
ça et quelles sont aussi les clés ?
Tu as encore trois bonnes heures. Ça
tombe bien, on a fait pipi avant.
Voilà. H alors je pense malheureusement
qu'il y a très très peu voire pas du
tout de compréhension psychologique dans
la plupart de nos gouvernants. Je veux
pas leur jeter la pierre, ils vivent ils
travaillent dans des circonstances
difficiles. Mais jusqu'ici je n'ai pas
vu de signes de compréhension de cette
mécanique humaine que je viens de
résumer très à l'extrême. Et donc
malheureusement la plupart des solutions
que sont prises sont prises en aval du
phénomène. Quand il y a du terrorisme
tout d'un coup on sait on va faire des
prisons, on va renforcer les frontières.
Au lieu de se dire "Mais pourquoi est-ce
qu'il y a du terrorisme ? les les les
terroristes du Bataclan et et des
terrasses et puis en Belgique
concomitamment quasiment à l'aéroport de
Bruxelles et dans le métro et ben ils
sont nés dans le Serra et ils étaient
des enfants des écoles ici. Et ce qui
fait que dans ce système scolaire, il y
a pas une intention à ce que tout le
monde ait sa place, une intention à
l'inclusion, une perspective de vie, de
déploiement, que chacun se sente reconnu
et heureux d'être là. Comment est-ce
qu'on n' pas mis euh des budgets sur
l'éducation faire des classes plus
petites avec des des des professeurs
beaucoup mieux rémunérés pour qu'il soit
disponible à accompagner chacun à
percevoir les sensibilités des uns des
autres et que chacun sente qu'il est
encouragé à être là, qu'il est bienvenu
et qu'il va contribuer contributiv la
formule qui va contribuer à la planète
mais malheureusement c'est pas du tout
l'attitude. On est toujours en aval du
phénomène et on a bien vu pendant le
Covid de nouveau au lieu de privilégier
la santé, l'hygiène de vie, prendre soin
de soi, aller respirer dehors, faire du
sport, manger sainement, éviter le sucre
et les graisses, en toutes ces choses de
base d'une bonne santé. On a dit
simplement "Restez chez vous, mettez un
masque et faites-vous vacciner." Mais
c'est
tellement pauvre comme mesure de santé.
Nous avons absolument besoin d'être
infiniment plus dans
l'anticipation de notre vivre ensemble
et je recommande évidemment d'apprendre
des clés de pacification de soi au
service de la pacification avec l'autre.
Ça c'est ton grand point. C'est-à-dire
un citoyen pacifié est un citoyen
pacifiant et j'ajoute tout de suite il
est activement pacifiant. Il est passif
dans son coin à fumer un pétard peace
and love dans une ambiance bisounours.
Ce que j'observe dans mon travail depuis
d'années, c'est qu'à partir du moment
une personne a appris à se pacifier, à
trouver le meilleur de soi et à sentir
qu'elle peut le mettre au service du
monde et apprécié pour ça. Elle a un app
une appartenance soutenante et de
l'interaction heureuse avec les autres.
Elle est activement pacifiante. Elle
elle elle entraîne un sorte de drive de
pacification. Elle a une dégaine à
travers les intempéries de l'existence
qui donne envie. Et c'est ça que je
souhaite encourager. J'aime rappeler
qu'on sait faire la guerre à travers le
monde et c'est bien ce qu'on a à quoi on
assiste aujourd'hui parce qu'on s'y
discipline. Il y a des écoles de guerre,
il y a des armées, on s'y drille, on s'y
discipline. J'en sais quelque chose.
J'ai encore fait mon séisme militaire à
l'époque, il était obligatoire en
Belgique et je n'avais pas encore
connaissance de la de la nonvolence.
Donc après mes études de droit, je me
suis dit je vais faire un séri militaire
un peu costaud. Ça va m'énergiser.
J'aime être dehors, j'aime le sport,
l'activité physique et donc je deviens
officier au régiment paracommando pour
être très sanglier le sanglier. C'était
pas toi derrière le sanglier ? Non.
Et donc je je je fais militaire et je en
15 mois de soci militaire, je suis un
officier prêt à emmener une troupe au
combat. C'est quand même dingue
d'imaginer ça. Pardon, j'étais
lieutenant et euh imaginez simplement
qu'on ait remplacé le séisme militaire
qui est évidemment obsolède et qui est
pas nécessaire par un service civil de
juste quelques mois pour donner des clés
de pacification et de connaiss
connaissance de soi et qu'on mette du
budget pour éduquer les personnes à se
connaître, connaître les autres, médier
les conflits. Les conflits sont
inévitables, on n'est pas dans un monde
de business. Mais comment faire que on
puisse rendre les conflits féconds qui
permet de passer à un autre point de
rencontre ? Je me dis que nous pourrions
vraiment nous former à des choses
vraiment utiles et que il est temps
effectivement d'apprendre si on sait
faire la guerre à faire la paix. Il nous
avons besoin d'une discipline de paix.
Tu sais tu parles latin un peu non ?
Ouais, j'ai fait du latin à l'époque.
Oui. Si vis pasem parapassem ou
parabellom. par à Belou jusqu'ici dans
notre système de pensée et comme on part
à Belou si tu veux la paix prépare la
guerre on prépare la guerre et alors on
a la guerre parce que c'est c'est la
prophétie qui s'autoréalise. Alors je je
suis intimement persuadé parce que tu me
parles d'empathie, tu me parles de de
sentir l'autre. Est-ce que tu as eu une
conduite introspective ? Est-ce que tu
t'es mis à la place du politique ? Et
est-ce que tu as essayé de trouver une
réponse à leur façon de gérer notre
société, de d'utiliser du nudge pour
canaliser la plebe dans un sens ou dans
un autre ? Est-ce que tu as essayé
d'avoir cette conduite de te mettre à
leur place ? Est-ce que tu as essayé de
les comprendre ? Est-ce que tu t'es dit
"Bon, j'ai essayé de les comprendre, ils
sont complètement en dehors de la boîte,
ils sont complètement déconnectés, ils
sont dans un autre monde. Ils ne
connaissent pas les racines de la pleb
du peuple. Où est-ce que tu t'es dit
c'est des [__] d'arrivistes, ils ont
ils ont forcément rien à branler ?"
Pardon pour le le le vocabulaire fleuri.
Où est-ce qu'ils sont tellement pris
dans le tumulte de la gestion
symptomatique d'une société profondément
malade que ils ont des œillères ? Quelle
a été ton analyse face à cette passivité
intellectuelle ayant des répercussions
sur des générations ?
Hm Ce qui me paraît, c'est profondément
dans mon travail d'accompagnement des
personnes, c'est qu'on ne peut pas
arrêter un train euh et le faire changer
de direction sans avoir ralenti. Le
train roule, roule, roule. Si l'on veut
pouvoir arriver à une de ces plaques
tournantes, comme on en voit dans
certaines gares de triage, il s'agit
d'apprendre à ralentir pour prendre un
autre axe. Et c'est c'est la le besoin
d'apprendre à se ressourcer, à trouver
des moments d'intériorité.
Vous êtes en France et nous le sommes
aussi en Belgique, les spécialistes des
réunions gouvernementales jusqu'à 3 ou
4h du matin. C'est absurde de d'imaginer
qu'on puisse tirer quoi que ce soit
d'intelligent, de profond et de
visionnaires, de gens qui sont au café
depuis à boire du café, je veux dire,
depuis 15h et qui sont épuisés. Il y a
vraiment à revisiter profondément les
modes de gouvernance. J'ai un ami belge
avec qui j'ai écrit un petit bouquin au
moment des attentats. On a écrit un
petit livre qui s'appelle La paix, ça
s'apprend. précisément pour conjurer la
vieille phrase latine si tu veux la
paix, prépare la guerre. Ben non, si tu
veux la paix, prépare-la. Prépare la
paix. C'est ça la clé. Et dans ce livre,
on est il y a des il y a des des outils,
des processus, des clés, des drills, des
rituels qui permettent de se pacifier
petit à petit. Il devrait être connu du
grand public, quoi. C'est pas un enjeu
de développement personnel, hein. Là, on
a vraiment dépassé les enjeux du
développement personnel. Ce dont je te
parle là, c'est des enjeux de de
développement social durable et pour
lequel il y a des outils. Et
effectivement, plutôt que de mettre du
budget à réarmer tout le monde pour
faire la guerre, est-ce qu'on ne
mettrait pas infiniment moyen de budget
mais du budget beaucoup plus utile à
éduquer les personnes à la capacité
d'apprentissage est considérable.
Regarde à quelle vitesse les jeunes ont
appris à jongler sur internet, à
connaître les outils et cetera. Mais mes
filles jonglent sur ces outils tellement
mieux que moi, moi j'y pige quasiment
rien. La capacité d'apprentissage est
considérable. C'est pas ça le problème.
Le problème c'est de pouvoir proposer
des outils en indiquant combien ils sont
bénéfiques. Mais pour ça, il faut les
connaître. Et donc ce que j'observe
c'est que les gens qui sont aux
commandes, qui sont les decision makers
dans notre société ne commencent à
transformer leur attitude par rapport à
leur pouvoir d'action que quand ils ont
été titillés par la vie qui a eu un
divorce, une maladie, un accident et que
tout d'un coup à l'occasion de cette
secousse, ils se sont un peu interrogés
sur les questions de base. Qui suis-je ?
Où courge et à quoi ser ? question
métaphysique que tout se pose. Question
métaphysique que tout le monde se pose
et pas qu' boutade d'ailleurs, mais
parfois parce que la vie vraiment nous
met au pied du mur et que il est temps
d'y trouver une réponse. Alors là, le
changement peut arriver. Je souhaite
simplement que nous puissions de façon
collective faire prendre conscience que
nous avons besoin de revisiter nos
systèmes de management. Euh mon ami
David Vandrebrook avec qui j'aiécris ce
petit bouquin La P ça s'apprend qui est
un historien, un chercheur très apprécié
en Belgique, très très connu euh
titulaire de nombreux prix et bien euh a
écrit un petit bouquin qui s'appelle
contre les élections pour montrer que
les élections c'est obsolète. En tout
coup, on vote et puis tout d'un coup, on
laisse faire pendant 5 ans un
gouvernement sur des choses que qu'on a
pas vraiment décidé. Et il a fait un
exercice qui correspond à peu près à la
convention citoyenne en en France. Il a
fait un exercice avec plus de 1000
personnes rassemblées dans des grandes
salles pour décider d'enjeux de société.
En 3 4 jours, 1000 personnes tirées au
hasard dans la population arrive à
prendre des des décisions. Pourquoi ?
Mais parce qu'ils sont pas en train
d'essayer de garder leur mandat. Ils
sont en train de faire un service au
bien commun et c'est ça qui devrait
s'instaurer. Tu es pas un peu bisounours
?
C'est extrêmement pratico pratique que
de mettre des gens ensemble pour décider
ensemble.
Ce qui est biso c'est d'imaginer que
l'on va franer la société en votant un
jour et en lâchant le pouvoir à un
gouvernement et à des présidents ou ou à
des premiers ministres dont on a lâché
complètement les reines. On voit la
catastrophe un peu partout dans nos
pays. Il faut pas faire un dessin. Nous
avons besoin d'être consultés beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus proche d'être Tu as
déjà discuté avec la la ce qu'ils
appellent la upper classe. de censé
gérer les problèmes du monde et nous
guider vers un avenir meilleur. Est-ce
que Est-ce que tu as senti ce racisme de
classe quand il
s'exprime sur la plebe ?
Alors euh je perçois ce que tu veux
dire, une sorte d'élitisme. Nous avons
les bons diplômes, nous sommes au bon
endroit, nous avons fait euh nos preuves
et il y a donc une espèce d'illusion
d'être dans le club des gens qui savent
et qui ont raison. Et et ça asseoit des
certitudes. C'est effrayant de voir ça
effectivement, cette prétention à avoir
raison. Ouais. Je crois qu'il est plus
que temps de faire preuve d'humilité et
de considérer et de consulter la
population, les gens, les citoyens. Eux
devraient consulter, est-ce que ils
devraient faire la démarche ? Est-ce que
tu penses qu'ils ont la
démarche pour ils sont mur pour cette
démarche là ? pour consulter la
population, non ? Pour se consulter,
consulter eux-mêmes, je pense
profondément que chacun a cette
capacité, pas tout le monde a cette
volonté parce que c'est dérangeant
d'aller voir ses propres
fonctionnements. Ça nous demande de
scoltiner son ego, de le regarder bien
en face pour petit à petit s'en défaire.
Et ça, je suis pas sûr que la plupart
des personnes qui sont tout au poir
aient envie de faire ce travail là.
Pourquoi ? Parce qu'on les a sélectionné
pour être des petits requins dans un
monde de gros requins. Bah, c'est
peut-être une caricature ce que tu dis
là, mais c'est pas complètement faux.
Toujours un peu de vrai dans la
caricature, non ? Ouais, sans doute.
Ouais. Et tu penses que c'est pas trop
tard qu'on se retrouve avec une classe
d'élite qui a sauté dans le grand bain
qui découvre les réels problèmes d'une
société
thermoindustrielle d'accession aux
ressources, de comportement prédateurs
et des chiquers géopolitiques et qui en
fait ils sont proches du burnout et qui
courent ils courent ils courent ils
courent ils courent et ils imposent
imposent imposent imposent et ils ne
consultent pas ils ne consultent pas il
ne consultent pas et il y a plus de
pilote dans l'avion. a plus de pil dans
l'avion, c'est l'impression que ça
donne. Et il me semble que euh la
population est aujourd'hui plus éveillée
en terme de conscience et de conscience
élargie des enjeux du monde que nos
dirigeants qui sont à mon avis
complètement pris par leur quotidien et
la la la frénésie d'essayer de pas
perdre leur leur voix ou leur poste. Je
je
je je vois la l'absurdité de rétablir
des pesticides alors qu'on sait que ça
va nous bousiller complètement la
biodiversité. Je vois qu'on la
population arrive à faire en sorte qu'on
qu'on arrête une autoroute inutile et le
gouvernement continue à vouloir refaire
l'autoroute. Et c'est hallucinant de se
dire mais comment est-ce que les les
gouvernements n'écoutent pas davantage
le le l'énergie du peuple, le le de la
population, la conscience qui qui
souhaite une pacification, un
ralentissement revenir à des valeurs
plus ourses.
Et votre président balaye ça en disant
on va pas revenir à la lampe à huile.
C'est pas ça la question du tout mais il
y a une covid Oui, c'est les amiches.
C'est ça. Les amiches de temps en temps
c'est ça. C'est vraiment pensé Oui,
pourquoi c'est vraiment la pensée
binaire et divisante comme je le mis
tout à l'heure, soit ceci soit cela. Ben
non, c'est et ceci et cela. On peut très
très bien euh faire un un de très beaux
progrès dans des énergies renouvelables.
Toi en tant que toi en tant que de
psychologue quand tu entends par exemple
George Bouge dire soit vous êtes avec
nous soit vous êtes contre nous quand on
entend la parole politique
européenne où il n'y a jamais de
troisème voix
possible c'est fait exprès. Ils s'en
rendent compte, ils s'en rendent pas
compte. Tu analyses le discours
politique ou pas ? Oui, je pense pas
qu'il s'en rendent compte. Je pense que
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs bisousse quand
même hein. Je quoi si je suis ours ? Ben
les les les personnes qui nous écoutent
jugeront. Euh je je parle
de en observant la division qu'instaure
la pensée binaire entre soit ceci soit
cela, comme c'est divisant. Je l'ai vécu
moi-même profondément. J'ai, je peux le
dire sur le plan de ma vie affective.
J'ai dit que j'ai commencé comme ça en
disant que j'étais dans un célibat
défensif jusqu'à quasiment 40 ans.
J'avais peur de l'engagement parce que
j'avais peur de perdre ma liberté.
J'avais encodé. Être aimé, c'est être
contrôlé. Bon, je vais pas vous faire un
dessin. Dès que je reçoivais de l'amour
dans mon enfance, j'avais l'impression
de devoir correspondre au projet
maternel. Et donc, je me suis dit moi
j'ai pas du tout envie de d'être
contrôlé. Donc j'ai envie d'avoir des
amourettes mais je veux pas m'engager.
Mais soit je suis aimé et alors je suis
contrôlé, soit je suis pas aimé mais au
moins je suis libre. Alors ça c'est la
pensée d'idé. J'aurais pu passer ma vie
dans un célibat tristounet à à à à
picoler ma
solitude. J'ai appris grâce à la
pratique de la non viiolence à
réconcilier et j'ai besoin d'être un
être complètement libre et j'ai vraiment
le goût de m'engager dans une relation
stable et durable. Le va remplacer
complètement le ou. Et plus tard, j'ai
fait le choix de quitter ma vie de
juriste et j'étais dans la même tension.
Soit je fais des choses qui m'ennuient,
qui ont plus beaucoup de sens mais qui
rapporte bien et je je suis en sécurité.
Soit je fais un un choix de vivre plus
avec ma sensibilité de la mettre au
monde, d'aider les gens et de travailler
au bien comment, mais je vais manger des
des des racines parce que j'aurais pas
de quoi vivre. Soit soit et j'ai
réconcilié ça en disant ben non, j'ai
besoin de faire confiance. Quand mettant
au monde ma sensibilité, en faisant ce
que moi j'aime faire, je trouverai une
sécurité suffisante. Réconcilier. Je
pense pas que nos dirigeants soient dans
une pensée réconciliante, ils sont dans
une pensée divisante. C'est à ce point
que je veux arriver. Pourquoi ? C'est
une vieille habitude. C'est un résultat
à mon avis de la pensée cartésienne.
Alors, merci à la pensée cartésienne
d'avoir mis de l'ordre dans le désordre,
c'est sûr. Mais il y a pas que ça. La
pensée cartésienne, malheureusement, il
y a des tiroirs qui s'opposent. On tire
l'un, on retire l'autre. Ben, nous avons
absolument besoin de sortir de cette
dualité et de nous inspirer euh
de la fécondité qu'il y a lorsqu'on fait
danser les polarités entre elles. Tu
m'autorises à être l'avocat du diable ?
Bien sûr. Comment je fais pour t'énerver
?
Essaye. J'essayie. Oui. Qu'est-ce que tu
connais à la guerre économique ?
Qu'est-ce que tu connais à la calorie ?
Qu'est-ce que tu connais à la
psychologie des foules ? Quand les gens
n'ont pas 2200 calories, quand tu vois
que tu leur annonces un confinement
certes mal annoncé et qui se précipite
pour aller acheter des rouleaux de PQ et
des tubes de Nutella, tu as pas
l'impression d'être hors sol. Moi, on
fait une expérience de pensée hein. Moi
politique, je suis au courant que il y a
potentiellement un corona virus
militarisé par les Chinois qui
d'ailleurs sont très agressifs avec nos
entreprises depuis une
certa. En plus, on leur a fourni un
laboratoire pour faire les conneries. Ça
risque de nous retomber sur la tête. Et
en plus, on a une population de trépané.
Et on sait que c'est des trèpanés parce
que ça fait des années qu'on leur fait
avaler n'importe quoi. Et là selon
Gustave Lebont, si cette foule commence
à s'énerver, ils vont avoir tous cet
endage mental et ça va se terminer en
Pugila. Alors toi
psychologue, tu me fais rire. La
troisième voix, l'empathie, se projeter.
Moi, j'ai des choses concrètes à gérer.
Éviter que les gens se tapent dessus. Et
en plus, j'ai des puissances étrangères
très agressives face à mon
économie et c'est très très compliqué.
Tu penses que je vais avoir le temps de
m'attarder sur tes petites pensées ?
Alors, il va être temps de prendre ce
temps si tu veux que je te réponde cache
parce que ne pas tirer les conséquences
de la crise et ne pas prendre conscience
que ça a généré un désarrois pas
possible, une perte de sens, une
impression de solitude, de désarroi, de
nonsistance à personne en danger et ne
pas s'occuper de ça pour immédiatement
mettre en place un processus d'éducation
à la connaissance de soi, à la gestion
émotionnelle, à l'empathie pour l'autre,
à la médiation des conflits pour
éveiller les consciences. Ça c'est
vraiment un système complètement
déconnecté de la réalité. On a affaire à
des technocrates mais pas à des humains.
J'ai 3300 milliards de dettes. Je vais
avoir le FMI qui va débarquer pour me
racheter les bijoux de
famille. Et l'un n'empêche pas l'autre,
hein. Peut-être qu'il y avait des
mesures d'urgence à prendre. Peut-être,
je vais pas revenir sur ce sujet-là.
Mais ne pas faire en sorte que les
enjeux de relation humaine, de sens, de
vivre ensemble soient privilégié
immédiatement dès que la crise est
passée. Ça, je ne peux pas comprendre
comme je ne peux pas comprendre lorsque
l'on voit euh toute la violence que tu
as rappelé là, ce jeûne et les coups de
couteau et
caé mis en place des classes plus
petites avec plus de professeurs, avec
du sport, de l'activité physique. Quand
je me suis occupé de jeunes dit de la
rue, j'ai vu tellement d'actes de
prédation et de déprédation lié à la
difficulté de se sentir vivant
physiquement. Les jeunes ne se sentent
pas vivants. Ils en ont marre de jouer
du volleyball dans des cours en béton.
Ils ont besoin de faire de l'escalade,
de faire du cheval, de faire du sa en
parachute. C'est ce que nous faisions
dans l'association. Alors, on cherchait
des messes, il fallait de l'argent
effectivement et on a trouvé. Mais je te
jure que le gamin qui a passé sa journée
en escalade sur des voies dans une
nature magnifique et on campe le soir et
on monte une tente et on fait un feu et
on partage une bière, il a pas envie
d'aller délinquer à gauche ou à droite.
Il est bien, il est là, il est centré.
Et qu'est-ce qui est nourri ? Je
l'analyse dans mes mes livres. C'est la
ch ce phénomène. Bon, c'est mon premier
livre. Cess d'être gentil, soyez vrai.
Sorti il y a il y a 23 24 ans. Cess
d'être gentil, soyez vrai. La vraie, la
qualité de la relation. Et bien ces
jeunes, qu'est-ce qui les fédère et qui
fait qu'ils ont pas envie d'aller
délinquer pour prendre ce mot-là ? Euh
c'est la chaleur de l'amour. On a fait
une journée avec de l'amour, enfin de la
camaraderie, de l'affection, de
l'amitié. C'est la clarté du sens. Ça a
du sens de faire des choses ensemble
dans lesquelles on s'entraîne, on se
passe le truc et cetera. Et il y a un
profond respect pour chacun. On n' pas
jugé qui fait quoi, qui en a longtemps
attiré dans sa maison, dans ses
institutions de détention et cetera. Il
est urgent de créer une société dans
laquelle tout le monde ressent la
chaleur de l'amour. Tout le monde
ressent le profond respect pour son
identité et tout le monde sent que la
vie a du sens. Ça ça devrait être la
base de la scolarité. Et c'est
malheureusement pas ça. Les enfants vont
à l'accueil avec la boule au ventre en
ayant peur de manquer de respect, d'être
bousculé, d'être harcelé et ils
reviennent terrorisés à l'idée que la
journée va recommencer demain. Les
enfants devraient aller à l'école dans
la joie d'apprendre et revenir dans
l'enthousiasme d'avoir appris. Qu'est-ce
qu'on attend pour changer ça ? Est-ce
que c'est biso ce que je raconte ? Tu
connais la thermodynamique ? Tu me
réponds pas. Je suis pas là pour
recevoir des questions. C'est moi qui
pose des questions ici.
Tu me raconteras un petit peu comment
les gens ensuite quand on aura éclusé
tous ces sujets un peu aride, tu me
raconteras comment les gens attendent ce
que les gens attendent d'une
psychothérapie ou d'une du d'un
thérapeute. Revenons revenons à nos
sujets. Arrête de me faire des petites
effets de manche pour me déconcentrer
là.
Et quand tu te retrouves en
thermodynamique et que tu as de
l'instabilité, là on parle d'une société
intriquée avec un degré de prédation
entre les puissances, une course à
l'échalotte pour les ressources. Tu vois
le Groenland, tu vois l'Ukraine, tu vois
tout
ça. Si on crée encore plus
d'instabilité, qu'on change, qu'on met
ton système d'amour, d'empathie, de je
te tends la main, je suis bienveillant,
je t'écoute, on essaie de diversifier
notre vocabulaire pour exprimer
correctement ses
émotions, on va créer de l'instabilité
encore plus et ça va péter d'autant plus
vite quand la pyramide de dette va être
attrapée par la réalité de production
énergétique et que dans les
supermarchés, tu auras soit des prix qui
explosent
soit moins de choses dans les
supermarchés. Je te parle que des
produits de base. Je te parle pas du
rouge à lèvres de la dernière
influenceuse ou de la dernière paire de
basket fait par des enfants à l'autre
bout du
monde. Quand les politiques sont
pris dans ce cette
tornade, est-ce que toi tu te mets à
leur place en te disant bon si je
ralentis, les Chinois me mangent. Si je
ralentis en production d'armement, les
Russes me tombent dessus, les Américains
me mettent des couteaux dans le dos.
Moi, petit français, j'ai essayé déjà de
leur expliquer que le climat, il va
falloir un petit peu ralentir et ça a
pas l'air de
fonctionner. Tu te mets à leur place un
peu.
C'est sans doute complètement au-delà de
mes compétences. Ce que moi j'aide, ce à
quoi je veux aider, c'est ce couple qui
est en dispute parce qu'il se projettent
l'un sur l'autre des images d'ennemis et
qu'ils ont juste besoin d'apprendre à se
parler, à s'écouter. Diplomatie là.
Non non, je je je parle de là où je peux
agir moi. Euh et euh je te donne juste
quelques exemples. Le couple, la
famille, les enfants, euh faire en sorte
qu'on peut accompagner son adolescent
vers l'expansion et l'ouverture, les
classes, sortir du système de de
compétition et de de répression de
l'initiative personnelle qui est
malheureusement toujours très très fort
en place. Ce que je crois profondément,
c'est que si nous étions encouragés à
vivre les relations humaines depuis
l'enfance dans un autre climat, il
émanerait de cette population une toute
autre façon de gouverner. Et c'est ben
non, c'est pas trop tard.
Mais dans nos systèmes de pensée, ça ce
sera l'objet de mon prochain livre qui
sort l'année prochaine et nous sommes
pris dans ce que j'appelle des
enfermement. Des enfermements dans des
systèmes de pensées autobloquants. Je te
m pardon qui c'est qui me c'est l'enfer
qui me m ça et je je donne juste deux
exemples. Ce que j'appelle la culture du
malheur, le goût du drame, l'attachement
à la souffrance, le verre
systématiquement à voie à moitié vide,
les gens qui se plaignent de tout sans
rien construire, sans prendre les choses
en main. sans bouger les choses, ce
qu'on peut bouger là où on peut bouger,
même si c'est tout à fait menu. Cette
habitude de se plaindre et d'avoir un
attachement au drame est incroyable et
nous plombe complètement. Je le vois
dans l'accompagnement des personnes.
Tant que je suis dans cet état d'esprit,
je ne bouge pas collectivement. Nous
avons besoin de sortir de ça et de
savoir par où ça va aller, par où le
verre est plutôt à moitié plein qu'à
moitié vide et comment nous allons
tabler là-dessus pour bouger les choses.
Deuxième enfermement, c'est l'habitude.
C'est nouveau une culture des rapports
de force combatif. le fait d'être accro
à l'affrontement quand on n'est pas
d'accord demandons aux gens qui nous
écoutent et quand vous êtes pas d'accord
avec l'autre et que tout d'un coup ce ce
vieux copain cette ce conjointe cette
conjointe votre ados adorable est en
train de dire des choses avec lesquelles
vous êtes pas d'accord qu'est-ce qui
circule en vous est-ce une profonde
empathie pour cet humain qui pense
autrement que vous est-ce un accueil
inconditionnel de la différence est-ce
de la curiosité pour la mécanique
humaine qui est si différente et ben je
pense que si nous étions dans une salle
parce que je donne excellent cet exemple
en conférence assez souvent, on
entendrait rire parce que lorsque le
différent apparaît dans une relation
avec un proche ou avec un collègue au
travail, peu importe, ce qui circule en
nous, c'est plutôt un peu d'adrénaline,
une petite tension nerveuse, une
agitation cardille et l'envie de trouver
assez rapidement le gourdin de
chromagnon pour dire "J'ai raison et
d'ailleurs tu as tort. Paf ! Ou bonbon,
fous-moi la paix, je vais dans ma
grotte." Et donc, il y a gourdin où il y
a grotte mais il y a pas. C'est ça
l'enjeu que nous avons absolument besoin
d'apprendre depuis la maternelle. C'est
pour ça que je peux pas jouer moi
aujourd'hui sur la géopolitique, mais ce
que je souhaite, c'est que l'éducation à
la qualité de la rencontre avec soi,
avec les autres soit une priorité.
Accordons-nous sur ce désaccord.
J'ai pas vu de désaccord, hein.
Quand tu quand tu me donnes ces paroles,
est-ce que tu as vu comment on avait
géré les gens qui n'étaient pas d'accord
? Maintenant, il y a des gens qui sont
pas d'accord parce qu'on leur a tapé
dessus. On leur a dit, "Tu es
complotiste, tu es machin, tu es
d'extrême droite, tu es stupide, tu es
un
imbécile." Comment il fallait faire pour
réconcilier ces gens-là et trouver une
voix d'écoute mutuelle ? Il fallait
faire ça, prendre son gourdin et dire
"Tu es
stupide." Il fallait peut-être dire "Je
vais t'écouter." Mais oui, bien sûr. "Je
vais échanger." Oui, je ne vais pas te
juger, mais je vais te donner peut-être
des clés dans la nuit.
Est-ce que tu as analysé cette ce
phénomène très occidental de gestion des
complotistes avec cette agressivité,
cette façon
d'ostraciser et qui génère
des adhérences, des repli, des
endoctrinements où il y a des
opportunistes qui se mettent, nous on
appelle ça les nouveaux gourous pour
avoir du succès, de l'argent, de la fame
et ainsi de suite. Et sociétalement
parlant, le fait de rejeter des gens en
leur disant "Tu es un imbécile, tu ne
comprends pas, la science va
t'expliquer." et que 2 ans plus tard, il
y avait quand même des failles dans
l'argumentaire, ce qui ne fait que
endurcir les gens qui ne voulaient pas
tendre la main. Hm. Toi en tant que
psychologue, comment tu aurais comment
tu pourrais gérer ça et donner des
préconisations pour éviter de
reléguer une grande partie de la
population comme
des attardés, des méchants, des des
complotistes, des des vilains ? Comment
on fait pour remettre du
lien après avoir fait ça pendant des
années ?
Le fonctionnement que tu évoques là euh
traduit parfaitement la culture de
malheur, le goût du drame. On amplifie
la tragédie et on divise et la culture
des rapports de force et de
l'affrontement. On on crée des rapports
de pouvoir, on ostracise une partie de
la population comme tu l'as évoqué. Ce
sont des vieilles avétudes, c'est des
programmations. Ça a pu être peut-être
reptilien dans notre histoire depuis le
premier au minidé d'être plutôt dans un
goût du drame et se dire il faut se
protéger, il faut s'assurer la sécurité.
On peut comprendre sur le plan reptilien
mais ça se reproduit de façon
pavlovienne. C'est du copiercollé. On a
vu les gens se traiter se maltraiter
comme ça et on reproduit sans
discernement. Nous avons absolument
besoin d'apprendre à bien veiller les
uns sur les autres. à bien veiller à
dessin. J'utilise ce mot-là parce que la
notion de bienveillance notamment
éducative a été complètement maltraité
dans la presse par des échanges de
personnes qui n'ont pas entendu le mot.
Un l'éducation bienveillante est une
négation dans laquelle on veille. On
veille bien. Le veilleur, on est
vigilant. Le veilleur c'est un
guetteteur. Il est attentif, il est
présent. Il prend les mesures à temp, il
recadre, éventuellement il sanctionne et
on peut sanctionner sans punir. C'est
peut-être un autre sujet mais c'est il
est temps qu'on l'apprenne ça.
C'est-à-dire qu'on rappelle une valeur
et on demande de réparer bien sûr. Donc
il y a de la rigueur dans la
bienveillance et ça a été ça a échappé
bien sûr à des personnes qui n'ont pas
compris ça et qui pensent que c'est
c'est laissé tout faire et que c'est
bisounours et que ça fait des enfants
rois ou même des enfants dieux. Mon
dieu, on est loin de ça. Moi, j'ai élevé
mes enfants dans la bienveillance et
c'est des adultes hyper responsables et
conscientes et discernantes. Mais je
reviens à ta question, comment est-ce
qu'on traite ça ? Mais en en lançant un
processus d'éducation à la qualité de la
relation et de la rencontre et du
prendre soin, ça c'est les enjeux de la
décennie et sans doute du siècle qui
vient. On a absolument besoin
de réapprendre à prendre soin de soi,
des autres et de la et de la vie.
Je je fais un parallèle un peu flash,
mais puisqu'on on circule à travers
tout, je pense que la
maltraitance perpétuer sur la nature et
les ressources est le reflet
spectaculaire d'une maltraitance
perpétuée sur notre nature intime et sur
nos ressources intimes. Notre
sensibilité, notre délicatesse, notre
intuition, notre goût de la poésie, de
la tendresse. Tout ça est maltraité
depuis l'enfance et nous avons
absolument besoin d'apprendre à
respecter cette nature intime que nous
sommes en sorte d'avoir le goût de
respecter toute forme de vivant autour
de nous. Et c'est un chift majeur he
c'est pas bison de nouveau. C'est
vraiment un travail de construire un
autre système de pensée. Et pour
construire un autre système de pensée,
on le sait, les les neurosciences nous
disent que le nous avons des autoroutes
neuronales, la pensée s'engouffre dans
des systèmes de pensée automatisés sans
discernement. Ben donc il est temps de
prendre du recul et de réaliser si je
pense comme ça, j'agis comme ça,
j'obtiens ça. Est-ce que ça me convient,
ça convient à la société ? Ça convient à
à la nature ? Si la réponse est négative
à une de ces questions-là, il est plus
que temps que j'apprenne à pivoter à
l'intérieur de moi-même sur une sorte de
vis d'archimè intérieur pour donner une
image et réaliser, je pourrais
apprendre, ça s'apprend à penser plutôt
comme ceci, à ce moment-là, j'agirai
plutôt comme ça et j'obtiendrai plutôt
tel ou tel résultat. Mais il y a un
pivot nécessaire dans la conscience et
c'est h c'est tout sauf bisonours. Ça
c'est une hygiène de conscience. Ce sont
des rituel. C'est une pratique pour
frayer un nouveau chemin neuronal. Sinon
le risque on le connaît depuis Polvlaic.
Si l'on fait ce qu'on a toujours fait,
on obtient ce qu'on a toujours obtenu.
La seule façon de faire d'obtenir autre
chose, c'est de faire autrement. Et la
seule façon de faire autrement, c'est de
revisiter le système de pensée qui a
prévalu à ce que je faisais jusqu'ici.
Et ça, c'est le travail de notre
génération. Je dis revisiter les
systèmes de pensées qui ont prévalu à
l'ancien paradigme dont nous avons
absolument besoin de de de sortir. En
sorte de apprendre à penser autrement
pour créer une autre réalité. C'est pas
un travail simple, ça fait pas en un
jour et c'est absolument à ce travail
que les dirigeants devraient s'employer
mais ils le feront pas. Donc c'est la
population qui va le faire, j'en suis
convaincu.
C'est ta façon de te rassurer peut-être.
En tout cas, de me dire
que je
contribue à un phénomène que l'on voit
de nombreux endroits, c'est que les
êtres humains sont fatigués du
matérialisme, de la consommation à
outrance, du gaspillage et de ne pas
avoir de sens, d'être abruti devant des
écrans. Une bonne partie de la
population souhaite que la conscience
s'éveille pour retrouver d'autres
relations. Je une bonne partie de la
population, ça je pourrais pas te donner
le le cô. Je t'ai dit je t'ai dit
source, chiffre, sourcé, carré. Alors,
allons-y. Euh dans un bouquin qui moi
m'a beaucoup saisi et qui est une étude
faite aux États-Unis il y a une
vingtaine d'années qui s'appelle
l'émergence des créatifs culturels qui
prend un une étude de la population.
Considérant qu'une aujourd'hui entre 20
et 30 % de la population sont en train
par leur attitude, par leur système de
pensée qu'ils ont revisité par leur
pacification et leur ancrage, ils sont
en train de créer une nouvelle culture.
Le titre est très peu barbare,
l'émergence des créatifs culturels. Bon,
cette étude a été faite également en
France et il semble qu'entre 15 et 30 %
sont les endroits de la population sont
en train de nourrir cette nouvelle
culture. C'est une révolution
silencieuse disent les sociologues et
anthropologues qui font cette étude et
je trouve ça intéressant. Effectivement,
elle n'apparaît pas dans les journaux.
Elle n'est évidemment pas dans les
grands médias traditionnels. Et
cependant, moi, ce sont les gens que je
rencontre et les gens qui me qui
m'invitent. Et même dans les grosses
boîtes, je donne des conférences dans
des grosses structures, de plus en plus
de gens réalisent, on est à la fin d'un
système, le vieux système pyramidal est
en train de s'écrouler. On a besoin de
nouveaux modes de gouvernance et dans
des modes de gouvernance partagés et
collégiaux, il est temps qu'on se
connaisse et que les G ne prennent pas
toute la place. C'est plus un enjeu de
développement dit personnel, c'est des
enjeux de développement social durable.
Et je vois simplement ça. Alors, quelle
est la proportion ? Ben, je retiens
juste cette proportion de cette étude.
Les l'émergence récréative culturelle.
Entre 15 et 30 % de la population sont
en train de chifter en sur le plan de la
conscience. C'est plutôt rassurant pour
ceux qui comme moi, ont envie de changer
le monde. C'est tu veux changer le monde
? Contribuer
modestement. Et ce que je fais là ce
soir, c'est parle.
Ah mon dieu, je pense vraiment avoir
travaillé à défaire mon ego sur ce
planl. En tout cas, tu l'as poli ? Ben,
je l'ai poli. J'ai compris que j'avais
besoin de donner du sens à ma vie, que
ce qui me rend joyeux, heureux et et et
et déterminé, c'est de sentir que je
peux aider. J'ai perçu ça dans mon
métier d'avocat. Aider quelqu'un qui est
dans la mouise et trouver les bonnes
solutions, ça m'a vraiment donné
beaucoup d'énergie. Après quand je suis
occupé des gamins de la rue et que j'ai
pu voir que des activités leur donnaient
le goût de vivre, qu'il pouvaient lâcher
la clope ou la ou la ou ou ou ou ou la
fumette, c'est pas un syndrome de de du
sauveur ça. Ah si je m'oubliais, ce
serait syndrome du sauveur. Mais l'idée
c'est pas de s'oublier hein. Je fais ce
que j'aime parce que j'aime faire ça. Je
prends du temps pour moi. Je te l'ai dit
en redémarrant. J'ai un couple que
j'adore avec Valérie. On prend du temps
à nous deux, du temps d'intimité, de
joie. J'ai trois filles que j'adore. On
est beaucoup ensemble. On on se repose,
j'habite la campagne, je jardine, je
suis dans la forêt, je bûcheronne, je
rentre mon bois. Ces choses sont
essentielles. Donc j'aime agir pour les
biens publics, mais je vais pas m'y
moler sur ce travail-làin. Mais toi à la
place de quelqu'un qui fait un burnout
parce que bah les les chiffres de la
dépression en France, de consommation,
du de
psychotropes, que ce soit des
psychotropes en pharmacie ou des
psychotropes au coin de la rue. Ouais.
son révélateur d'un mal-être. Ah bah
mets-toi à la place d'un gars qui rentre
qui a un boulot de merde qui se fait
emmerder au boulot euh qui est fatigué
qui dort pas qui est stressé qui a des
problèmes avec ses enfants, que les
enfants ont des problèmes à l'école de
violence,
d'attention, d'hyperactivité à cause des
réseaux, de radicalisation sur X ou sur
Y qui a un salaire qui est à peine
couvre les besoins primaires.
Moi quand je t'entends parler, je me
fais l'avocat du diable. Je me dis
mais se réconcilier avec soi-même et
ainsi de suite, c'est un sport de
bobo. C'est un sport de mec qui vit à la
campagne, qui gagne plein de frquis avec
ses bouquins, qui a le temps de prendre
du temps, qui a le temps de de
s'accorder des plaisirs. Le côté
opérationnel de ton raisonnement, tu
peux le transposer comment ? sur
quelqu'un qui est en
souffrance, au travail, dans sa vie
personnelle, dans sa vie affective, qui
est en mode survie et qui tient
uniquement parce que au fond de lui, il
y a une petite voix qui sait et qui lui
dit "Ne tombe pas du côté du mauvais
côté de la force, mais il est il est en
train de s'épuiser et que matériellement
parlant et que biotopement parlant, si
je peux m'exprimer comme ça, ça va être
l'enfer.
tu vas lui dire "Bon, ils font commencer
petit à
petit." Sauf que quand tu as une
avalanche et une tempête de merde
au-dessus de la tête qui te dure depuis
des décennies de de génération en
génération, c'est compliqué de d'ouvrir
les yeux. Qu'est-ce que tu peux donner
comme conseil
? La
conscience que nous disposons tous d'un
pouvoir de nous transformer aussi
considérable qu'ignoré.
Et donc le besoin de s'ouvrir petit à
petit à l'idée je vais sortir de ma vie
subie où je pense jusqu'ici ça va,
jusqu'ici ça va, c'est ce que tu décris.
Je peux encore te dire un petit peu avec
les anolitiques et tous ces machinslà.
Et voilà. Et je vais sortir de ma vie
subie petit à petit, petit à petit. Je
vais apprendre à mieux discerner
qu'est-ce que j'aimais vivre, comment
j'aimerais le vivre petit à petit, petit
à petit. Rien de magique. C'est pas un
clic sur l'ordinateur. C'est de l'ordre
du jardinage. Petit à petit, je vais
trouver une vie, je vais m'orienter vers
une vie plus choisie. J'en sais quelque
chose. J'étais avocat à travailler 12h
par jour dans un métier qui m'emmerdait.
Pardonne-moi. Je gagnais correctement
permis. Ben, j'étais encore jeune
avocat. Mais mais je pourrais pas te
dire, c'était en belge, en gamb
l'époque. Non, c'était pas grand-chose
franchement. Qu'est-ce que ça pouvait
être ? Euh c'était peut-être 4000 € 3000
€ brut hein parce que je l'époque
c'était énorme. Ben ouais ben il faut
payer la secrétaire, il faut payer la
bagnole, il faut payer quand même a des
frais un bureau. Bon toujours est-il que
je j'étais dans une vie subie avec la
croyance. Je n'ai queun diplôme de
droit. Je ne peux faire du droit qu'à
vie. Tant pis, c'est pas c'est pas
grave. J'étais dans la culture du
malheur. Le le la culture du malheur
vient d'un petit vaccin qui est une
injonction. On n'est pas là pour
rigoler. Bah oui, on n'est pas là pour
rigoler. Je suis pas là pour rigoler.
Donc je subis mon métier. C'est petit à
petit que j'ai réalisé, on n'est pas sur
terre pour s'emmerder. On n'est pas sur
terre pour subir. Il doit y avoir une
autre façon d'être au monde. Qu'est-ce
que je pourrais faire pour ça ? Et petit
à petit, rien qu'en ayant ouvert ce
questionnement, tout d'un coup, un
bouquin, une émission, un ami, tac, un
petit cheminement. Ah oui, tu as fait ça
toi ? le copain qui lance qui avait
lancé l'association pour les jeunes de
la rue, il était lui-même avocat devant
reprendre un gros cabinet bourgeois de
Bruxelles. Il a dit "C'est pas ma vie,
moi je vais m'occuper des jeunes
délinquents." Il est devenu flic à la
police judiciaire de Bruxelles.
Desgrégolade social. On devient pas flic
quand on a une carrière d'avocat. Ah il
s'en foutait complètement. Moi, j'avais
été épaté. J'avais lu un article sur lui
dans les journalistes. Je veux
rencontrer ce gars-là. Et c'est
intéressant comme changement de vie. Ça
me parle. Donner du sens à sa vie. Je me
dis bon, il est dans la police. Moi, je
vais jamais le rencontrer. Le hasard. Le
hasard. existe-t-il ? Je me retrouve
dans un stage de parapente en savoir
avec une bande d'amis. Le copain, le
gars, il fait partie du stage là, il est
ami d'amis, on fait du parapente
ensemble. Et je dis "Mais tu as fait une
super carrière toi." Je dis "Ben écoute,
j'ai suivi ma voix intérieure et puis je
bavarde avec lui." J'ai dis "Mais
comment tu vas si bien ? Tu es
courageux, tu emmènes les jeunes ?" Mais
parce que je suis en thérapie. "Ah bon ?
en thérapie mais tu as l'air d'être le
héros quiemène les jeunes à travers le
monde. Et ben petit à petit, c'est ça
les déclics qui sont extraordinaires.
C'est pour ça que je dis sans aucune
crainte de de bisou nourousserie, nous
disposons d'un pouvoir pour nous
transformer aussi considérable qu'ignoré
dès que nous ouvrons la porte à l'idée
j'aimerais changer, je voudrais que la
vie a cette couleur ou ce goût-là, bien
sûr, j'y suis pas encore, mais ça aurait
plutôt cette teinte là et je commence à
rêver un peu de la vie que je voudrais
avoir. Quelque chose se tend. C'est un
peu comme si je jetais un cer volant
pour attraper le fil et bouger de où je
je bouge. Je le vois tous les jours dans
mon travail et les gens dont tu parles
qui sont jusque là dans la mouise avec
les gamins en difficulté, le boulot qui
dans la mer, c'est qui dével qui
développent des pathologies
psychiatriques sans son même sans rendre
compte compte. Voilà, c'est eux que je
rencontre dans mes sages. Je donne des
formations depuis 30 ans avec des gens
qui en ont juste ral bol par hasard. Ils
ont entendu une émission, ils sont
tombés sur un bouquin, quelqu'un leur a
dit "Moi, j'ai fait un stage quelques
jours qui a changé ma vie." Et ben
voilà, petit à petit les portes
s'ouvrent et j'ai tellement envie qu'un
jour le gouvernement contribue, je sais
pas s'il s'en occupera, à faire savoir
ça. Ne restez pas dans votre mouise.
Apprenez à vous connaître. Si le
gouvernement Si le gouvernement n'agit
pas,
n'impellement conscience, qu'est-ce qui
va se passer ?
Heureusement qu'il y a des émissions
comme toi pour faire pour faire
connaître d'autres approches et diffuser
le plus largement possible.
Qu'est-ce qui va se passer ? Je pense
qu'il risque de se passer ce que Martin
Luther King avait prévu. Si nous
n'apprenons pas à nous aimer comme des
frères, nous allons nous entretuer comme
des
imbéciles. Et il le disait très
clairement. Si nous n'apprenons pas, ça
s'apprend à nous aimer comme des frères,
c'est de l'apprentissage. C'est pas un
truc bisouours de nouveau. Apprendre le
respect, l'attention, l'empathie. Alors,
c'est pas du vocabulaire new edge, ce
sont les mots clés du vivre ensemble. Et
il y a une partie de moi qui est
fatiguée d'entendre la critique comme
quoi dès qu'on parle d'amour, de
tendresse, c'est un truc bisou nourours,
ce n'est pas fonctionnel, ça n'ira pas.
Mais demandons aux technocrates s'ils
nous ont créé un monde qui tient la
route, hein.
Ils vont me dire oui.
Bah la preuve, c'est qu'il est en train
de s'écrouler complètement, qu'on a
bousillé la biodiversité et qui demain à
Paris, il fait 27°gr au début du mois,
même pas on n même pas encore en mai.
C'est juste hallucinant. Euh c'est c'est
pas eux qui vont sauver le monde donc il
est plus que temps d'envisager une autre
façon de fonctionner. Comment on fait
pour propager ça à l'échelle de la
planète ? Ah ben dis donc tu m'emmènes
chaque fois beaucoup plus coin que là où
j'ai un pouvoir. Je trouve que tu as un
point de vue qui est très micro avec
tout le respect que je te dois. C'estàd
que tu tu guéris les cœurs, tu guéris
les âmes, tu guéris les esprits, tu les
guéris pas. C'estàd tu donnes
l'opportunité aux gens de trouver des
portes de sortie à leurs embrouills.
Merci de préciser ça. J'ai pas le
pouvoir de guérison de qui que ce soit.
Mais les gens peuvent apprendre des
clés. Oui, c'est c'est ils peuvent ils
peuvent apprendre. C'est il y a des
trucs très intéressants. Il y a des
vidéos de toi disponibles. Tu avais
moins de cheveux blancs et tu étais plus
actif. Euh euh là à l'échelle mondiale,
on est dans un système interconnecté,
intriqué avec un commerce globalisé, des
réseaux énergétiques
interconnectés, des politiciens qui font
des réunions à gauche à droite, qui ont
leur idéologie, qui doivent répondre
pour leurs et pour leur boutique et pour
leur
commerce. C'est pas trop tard.
C'està-dire que on est on est avec un
train qui a pas de frein, 33 tonnes sur
l'autoroute et et il y a plus de pilote
et on est parti, on est parti, on sait
pas quoi faire et si on fait autrement,
si on bifurque, le camion va se
retourner, le train va dérailler. Donc
comment on fait
pour
essayé à l'échelle mondiale ? Comment on
fait pour que on arrête les conflits
avec les Russes et les Ukrainiens ? On
arrête les conflits en Afrique, on
arrête les conflits prédateurs. Comment
on fait pour se protéger de la vengeance
des peuples qu'on a exploité ? Comment
on fait pour essayer de construire
? C'est un paradoxe parce qu'il y a à la
fois urgence. Or, ralentir est la clé.
Comment on gère ça ? Je sais pas. Je
sais pas. Je vois juste que pour pouvoir
avoir une attitude adéquate, centrée,
posée, ancrée, si possible inspirer, ça
demande de ralentir, de retrouver un
rythme plus doux, un rythme plus juste,
plus respectueux. Sinon, on est dans la
précipitation, dans l'agitation et donc
on entretient la précipitation et
l'agitation. Donc, je n'ai pas la
réponse à à la question. Ce que
j'observe, c'est que des
transformations socio-politiques
majeures sont arrivées dans l'histoire
récente par une montée de conscience.
Comment est-ce qu'on quitte tout d'un
coup l'appartête en Afrique du Sud alors
que ça aurait pu être un bain de sang,
que ça a été un bain de sang ? Tout d'un
coup, wou Nelson Manella sort de sa
prison, il est nommé président et petit
à petit, on réactive le pays, on fait
une processus procédure d'amnistie, on
essaie de travailler la réconciliation.
En tout cas, la partte se dissou sans
coup de feu, sans sans massacre. C'est
juste incroyable. Il y a une montée
conscience en Afrique du Sud là. Oui,
c'est pas toujours stable, mais il y a
quand même eu un changement
social-politique considérable. L'Union
Soviétique, quand j'étais à l'armée,
justement, on avait le rideau de fer, il
fallait connaître nos positions en cas
de guerre et cetera. Tout d'un coup, ce
rideau de fer qui était une insulte à à
la vie humaine, à la dignité humaine à
travers la l'Europe, se dissou de part
et d'autre. Alors, il y a eu un travail
derrière, je sais plus exactement
Corbatchevigan, toutes sortes de de
d'enjeux politiques dont je me souviens
pas très bien. Mais il y a en tout cas
tout d'un coup une montée de conscience
qui fait que dans un jour de fête en
1989, on démonte le le le mur et
Rostropovic vient nous jouer du
violoncel alors que ça avait été un
endroit où tellement de gens ont été
tués, fusillés et cetera. Qu'est-ce qui
fait cette montée de conscience ? C'est
c'est c'est la population qui fait ça.
C'est c'est à ça que nous pouvons
travailler. C'est à ça que moi je veux
travailler. Alors, tu pourrais dire que
c'est de l'ego ou pas ? Peut-être que
c'est simplement le goût d'avoir un sens
à sa vie. Contribuer à ce que la
conscience s'éveille à tous les niveaux.
Comment
tuexpliques que les psychothérapeutes,
les psychiatres, les psychologues, il y
a pas des associations, ils se mettent
tous autour de la table, ils font une
grande greffe de la
fin pour dire voilà, nous on est
censé guérir l'âme, guérir l'esprit,
guérir le cœur, guérir la société,
fluidifier les rapports, enlever la
violence, que les gens se connaissent
mieux. Comment tuexpliques que bah tout
ce beau petit monde prennent pas la
parole avec les conflits, les conflits
écologiques, les conflits armés, les
conflits économiques ? Comment
tuexpliques que ce petit monde est pas
pris conscience de la réalité ? Est-ce
que tu penses que la majeure partie
c'est un business ? C'est un petit peu
un business comme les éducateurs canin
après la sortie du film les 101
dalmatien. Pourquoi ça te fait marrer
? L'image est drôle. Ouais, c'est un peu
ce qui s'est passé hein. Tu sais ça
aussi des répercussions sur les abandons
de chiot à la SP. Mais est-ce que tu as
pas l'impression de voir là avec le
confinement, on écoute nous, on aime
bien écouter les gens mais on on aime
bien écouter les gens quand ils se
rendent pas compte qu'ils sont écoutés
parce queon arrive à
saisir leur un peu leur être. On entend
des psychologues, des psychothérapeutes,
des psychiatres dire "Oh là là, depuis
le confinement, mon planning il est
blindé." Ils savent plus où donner de la
tête. Ouais. Est-ce que tu as pas
l'impression que c'est aussi un business
que coach en mental, coach en machin,
faire ta psychothérapie de couple
machin, c'est aussi des gens qui se qui
s'improvisent ou qui pensent avoir les
clés mais que comme ils sont pris dans
un océan de problème, ils ne traitent
que l'écume des
choses. Ça peut être un risque
effectivement que ce soit juste un
accompagnement bénéfique d'une personne
sans occasion de transition. social,
c'est une possibilité. Je je pense que
la plupart des gens sont de bonne
volonté et sincères. Qu'ils gagnent leur
vie avec ça, il y a pas de malin. On va
bien se faire soigner chez le médecin et
on paye aussi son
médecin qui est peut-être un peu
d'opportunisme. Parfois des personnes
qui sont pas suffisamment formées, ça
arrive, il y a de mauvais avocats, de
mauvais comptables partout hein, mauvais
vétérinaires. De mauvais vétérinaires
aussi.
Ce que je vois en tout cas le symptôme
que tu montres, c'est une société qui va
mal et qui n'a pas trouvé les ressources
intérieures, qui ne sait pas que ces
ressources sont en elle parce qu'on ne
prome pas cette connaissance de soi.
Moi, il m'a fallu un temps fou de j'ai
fait 6 années de psychothérapie en
psychanalyse traditionnelle trois fois
par semaine pour apprendre cacheton
en payant bien chèrement tout ça et bien
pour réaliser que j'ai des ressources en
moi. Il y a une intelligence fine,
intuitive en moi. Donc je m'étais coupé
pour être quelqu'un très
logicoathématique avec mon cerveau di
gauge qui commandait ma vie. Mais
j'avais très très peu d'intelligence
émotionnelle, même si j'ai toujours aimé
euh écrire joliment et faire des poèmes
et des choses comme ça, mais je n'avais
pas d'intelligence pour me comprendre
moi. Et tout d'un coup, je enfin pas
tout d'un coup, petit à petit, j'ai
réalisé que nous avons tous une
ressource et c'est ça que j'enseigne
aujourd'hui, petit à petit apprendre à
faire confiance qu'il y a en moi de quoi
piloter ma vie très finement sans avoir
besoin d'aide extérieure. Mais ça, ça
devrait être appris depuis la
maternelle. De nouveau, tout envant qui
va à l'école devrait apprendre à savoir
qui je suis, comment je me sens.
Qu'est-ce que ça dit de moi ? Où est ma
boussole ? Où est mon or à moi ? Pas le
copiercollé de la société, mais ce qui
fait sens pour moi. Qu'est-ce qui me met
en joie et en expansion, en solidarité,
partage, mais aussi qu'est-ce qui
m'attrice ? Qu'est-ce qui me peine ?
Qu'est-ce qui me rend seul ou impuissant
? Ou qu'est-ce qui me fout en rage et
que j'ai besoin de comprendre avant que
de faire payer mon dépit aux autres ? On
revient à cette notion de
développement non plus personnel mais
social. C'est de l'hygiène de
conscience.
C'est de nouveau la notion pour moi que
la connaissance de soi est un enjeu de
santé publique. Et je dirais même parce
que ça c'était quelque chose que
j'emploie un mot que j'emploie depuis 20
ans mais depuis 10 ans avec les derniers
attentats, je me dis que c'est un enjeu
de sécurité publique. Tout citoyen doit
savoir piloter son existence pour être
quelqu'un d'agréable à vivre qui apporte
quelque chose et qui ne fait pas payer
aux autres ses dépits.
Tu te rappelles des quelques vers que tu
as pu écrire quand tu étais jeune ?
Oui, donne-moisen si tu m'autorises à te
demander.
Oui, un qui m'est revenu il y a pas si
longtemps que j'avais écrit sur un
ticket de train quand j'avais 17 ans et
que je faisais ma première année de
droit dans la ville de Namur et que je
mesurais que c'est sans doute pas ça que
j'allais faire toute ma vie.
Et j'ai écrit ceci : "Je voudrais être
de tous les de toutes les villes, de
tous les quais et de tous les ports pour
n'être plus seul avec ma jeunesse qui ne
sert à personne et qui m'en sert
moi." J'avais l'impression qu'avoir 17
ans ça servait à rien, que j'ai juste
entraîné une étude droit sans trop trop
de motivation et que ma vie ne servait à
personne. Et ben, il y avait là-dedans
la graine de ce que je fais aujourd'hui.
J'ai besoin de que ma vie serve, qu'elle
puisse être utile. Qu'est-ce que tu
projettes de cette conduite
introspective sociétale ? Qu'est-ce que
tu appelles conduite introspective
sociétale ? Le fait de prendre le temps,
de ralentir, de de
s'écouter. Voici venu le temps de la
contemplation silencieuse des moments
passés
ensemble. C'est essentiel. Les endroits
sur la planète où la longévité est
particulièrement significative. Il y a
quelques spots comme ça, je crois qu'on
les appelle des zones bleues. Ce sont
des personnes qui sont en rapport avec
la nature, qui ont une vie intérieure
profonde et une conscience de la
spiritualité de la vie. J'appartiens à
un plus grand que moi et chacun mettra
les mots qu'il veut. C'est pas forcément
religieux. Ça peut être simplement la
conscience que ben je suis pas arrivé
tout seul, je suis le fruit d'un couple
et la terre était déjà là avant moi.
Donc j'appartiens à plus vaste et je
peux honorer, célébrer ce plus vaste ou
bien je peux le saccager. Ça c'est des
clés fondamentales. Sentir que
j'appartiens à plus vaste que moi.
Je j'ai pu voir en m'occupant de des
gamins dit de la rue
combien de personnes plongent dans la
drogue ou dans l'alcool ou dans le jeu.
la fascination pour les jeux dans des
sectes ou dans des sectes par manque de
perception d'un absolu, de quelque chose
de plus vaste. Alors tout d'un coup, on
b on entre dans la la tragédie de se
noyer dans ses dans ses pratiques ou
dans ses ses appartences sectaires, le
cas échéant bien sûr, alors que le
discernement permet justement de sentir
que je peux dans ma conscience à moi me
relier simplement à la nature ou à mes
ancêtres, à la famille dont je viens. Je
ne suis pas arrivé par hasard comme je
l'évoquais. mais peut-être aussi plus
subtilement au fait que beaucoup de
traditions nous parlent de souffle. Il y
a un souffle qui fait que la vie est
vie, on l'appelle Dieu, on l'appelle
comme on veut. Et bien se relier à ça
donne du sens et beaucoup de jeunes le
perçoivent notamment dans la musique,
dans le champ, dans les spectacles,
quelque chose
souffle qui est au-delà de nos
individualités.
Quand tu vois que la jeunesse a de moins
en moins de mots de
vocabulaire, s'exprime
enomatopé, quand tu vois que cette
jeunesse perçoit 100 que l'avenir va
être encore plus difficile que ses
parents, se réfugie vers comme tu le
décrivais, l'addiction, la violence, la
fuite de
soi-même. Quand tu as une masse
inertielle tellement importante dans une
société profondément malade qui ne guide
que des gens vers une adaptation dans
cette dans ce système profondément
malade, être bien adapté dans ce système
profondément
malade, le choc que toi tu leur proposes
de faire, tu vas pas les faire bugger
encore plus ?
Et non et pas du tout que du contraire.
Tout d'un coup, c'est Ah, c'est
possible. Ah, une ouverture existe, des
méthodes, des pratiques, une une way
out. Je je peux envisager de de me
défaire de ce que je connaissais, du peu
que je connaissais de moi jusqu'ici, je
peux envisager de développer autre
chose. Mais non, mais c'est c'est
vraiment un un un appel d'air. Et je
pense franchement que par rapport au
système que tu évoques de la société que
nous avons créé, nous avons besoin de
travailler individuellement à ce que
Pierre Rabi appelait une insurrection
citoyenne et que rappelait d'ailleurs le
le le pape récemment décédé dans un
message qu'il a fait à à son âme bien
sûr un homme qui a souhaité aider les
les plus les plus pauvres les plus
démunis et et se mettre vraiment au
service de ça. En tout cas, j'apprécie
cette cette partie là de sa démarche
sans aucun doute
et je voyais le message qu'il avait
remis à Cyril Dion en disant manifester,
aller dans la rue, il faut faire bouger
le monde, on peut pas rester là.
J'apprécie ça, cette cet encouragement à
secouer et je souhaiterais que les gens
qui vont nous écouter puissent aller
dire à leurs patrons, nous avons besoin
de clés de connaissance de soi dans
notre entreprise. Nous avons besoin
d'apprendre à médier les conflits. On a
besoin d'un petit moment d'apprentissage
de l'intelligence émotionnelle. Tous les
parents parmi les gens qui nous écoutent
frapper à la porte des directeurs
d'école en disant c'est pas un truc
bisou d'ours que d'apprendre à médier.
On a absolument un besoin de faire que
nos élèves apprennent la médiation. La
médiation peut pas faire ça par exemple
au K d'Orset. Tu sais ce que c'est le K
d'Orset ? Oui. Oui. C'est les affaires
étrangères. Notre ministère des affaires
étrangères. Oui. Oui. Tu parles de
médiation ou est-ce que tu as suivi le
conflit russeau-rainien ? Bah oui.
Qu'est-ce que tu entends dans cette
médiation, dans cette
verbalisation au milieu des propagandes
de Pierre, Paul Jacques de
Sergay, Pop of 1, Pop of 2, la
population qui est tirée à gauche, qui
est tirée à droite, soit vous êtes avec
nous, soit vous êtes contre vous, contre
nous. Qu'est-ce qui se passe ? Est-ce
que tu crois que c'est possible encore
de leur apprendre la
médiation, la
diplomatie,
l'échange, que ce soit chez eux ou chez
nous ? Comment tu fais pour être en
médiation avec quelqu'un qui ne veut pas
?
De nouveau, tu m'emmènes dans des
sphères où j'ai pas de pouvoir d'action.
Je ne vois pas jusque là. Moi, si je
peux déjà aider des familles à médier
les conflits avec les ados et des
groupes dans l'entreprise à s'entendre
euh je ou des électeurs dans un village
à trouver un point commun à plus grande
échelle à plus grande échelle, ils sont
pas capables de le faire. Ah ben c'est
parce que si j'inverse la proposition,
comment est-ce qu'on va pouvoir médier
des conflits au niveau international
alors qu'on s'en poigne dans son couple
? Mais c'est ça la la réalité. Apprenons
de façon systématique quand on est en
conflit dans son coup à dire bah le
conflit ça fait partie de la vie hein
voilà on n'est pas de nouveau pas dans
un monde de biseau d'ours. On s'assoit
et on discute. On s'assoit disc on
discute vrai. Ce sont des gentils soyons
vrais. On se parle vrai de ce que
l'autre voudrait. On écoute. On apprend
à écouter. Et j'aime le rappeler
profondément. Écouter l'autre c'est
difficile. Écoutez c'est la fermeux.
J'adore les mimé. Écoutez, cela ferme si
les personnes qui nous écoutent ne
retiennent que ça de notre échange, on
aura fait faire un PC considérable pour
l'humanité. Écoutez, c'est la fermer,
c'est se mettre un moment de côté, c'est
voir son petit ego dans la convulsion de
dire "Je tu as tort parce que moi j'ai
envie que ceci patata tata. Je laisse
mon ego, je le connais, je le calme, tu
auras ton temps de parole tout à
l'heure. J'écoute pour mieux comprendre
ce qui se passe chez cet humainlà. Je ne
peux pas demander à cet humainlà
d'écouter cet humain-ci. Si je n'ai pas
d'abord écouté cet humainlà. Donc je
crée le climat d'écoute et d'empathie
que je souhaite recevoir en retour. Ça
c'est l'incarnation de la formule de
Gandhi. Be the change you want to see in
the world. Sois toi-même le changeant
que tu veux voir dans le monde. C'est
c'est un message boudhique ou
christique. C'est c'est un message de
souffle pour nous rassembler. J'apporte
là où je suis dans les enjeux mes menus
de ma vie quotidienne, j'apporte avec
rigueur la qualité d'être que je
souhaite voir se développer dans le
monde. Je ne vais pas pouvoir rêver
d'avoir des dirigeants empathiques et
qui cherchent du nous si moi je suis
dans le je je je je face à tut tu tu et
j'ai bousillé le nous. C'est ça ta vie ?
C'est ton message ? Oui.
This is the way.
Nous sommes sur terre pour apprendre à
cocré du nous. Je suis absolument
profondément habité par cette conscience
et je le vois tous les jours et tu le
vois et les personnes qui nous qui nous
écoutent le voient. La tablée familiale
qui rassemble tout le monde, la balade
en forêt qui réjouit la nuit la belle
étoile avec quelques copains, le feu
qu'on allume, le nous enchante. Il se
fait que nos petits égos peuvent le
bousiller et c'est ça que nous avons
besoin d'apprendre.
Je vais jeter un œil aux questions de la
communauté. Je t'en
prie.
Euh, ils veulent que j'invite Boris
Ciric. Attention la scène, je vais
toucher le PC qui est pas à la terre.
Bah oui, c'est Boris bien sûr.
Je je t'en lis une. Je t'en lis une de
Alors, Albert Jacard disait "Il faut
supprimer tout esprit de compétition à
l'école. Le moteur de notre société
occidentale est la compétition et c'est
un moteur suicidaire. Il ne faut plus
apprendre à être le premier. La question
c'est comment favoriser un climat où
l'accent serait mis sur l'être et la
coopération plutôt que sur la réussite
individuelle et la comparaison ? Merci à
ce cet auditeur de de préciser ça si
clairement. Ce sera exactement un des
enjeux de mon prochain livre de montrer
comment nos système éducatif amène la
compétition et la quête d'être le
premier, d'être valorisé et donc d'avoir
des likes sur sur internet ou de se
montrer le meilleur et d'avoir des
hypertrophiés. Il est temps de changer
ça et d'avoir des systèmes éducatifs qui
sont dans la collégialité, la convalité,
le partage, l'entraide comme certains
systèmes éducatifs des pays du nord qui
favorisent cela où les plus âgés
s'occupent des plus petits où on peut
travailler assis, couché sur des
coussins pour sentir que le corps a sa
place et on n'est pas coincé dans une
structure comme ça, assis sans bouger.
Il y a vraiment à revisiter en
profondeur les systèmes éducatifs. Ce
n'est pas un petit enjeu. Jusqu'ici, on
a apporté des modifications de 5 à 10 %
dans les systèmes éducatifs. C'est un
virage à 180° dont nous avons besoin
dont parlait d'ailleurs mon compatriote
Marc Lugs Guisi que tu as invité et qui
disait que déjà qui laisse passer la
lumière. C'est ça. Oui, c'est ça. Il un
petit peu
et et qui disait que déjà dans l'équipe
de Deor à l'époque dans dans les années
80 je pense, il était question que le
système éducatif change de 180° pour
permettre un vrai changement social. Je
suis conscient. Tu es conscient que euh
le fait de dire ça, les les primaux
adhérents ou accédant à cette élévation,
à cette conscience, tu les envoies au
caspip ?
Bah, il y a toujours des pionniers qui
s'en prendent plein de la tronche si tu
me permets l'expression. C'est
clair. C'est clair. Aujourd'hui, tu peux
expliquer pourquoi tu les envoies au
caspip ? Ben, je les envoie pas au
caspip mais je je je quand tu veux
changer un système forcément il y a des
essais et des erreurs avant de trouver
la bonne formule. Et donc clairement, ça
va pas pas se faire d'un coup, sinon ce
serait déjà fait depuis longtemps. C'est
compliqué à faire mais ça devient urgent
de le faire. Il y a heureusement des
initiatives SaLa qui commencent à se
mettre en place mais ça devrait être
beaucoup plus encouragé
par les structures. Je les envoies au
CASPIP parce que dans un milieu de
prédateur, de prédation, d'hyper
violence, je te marche sur la tête, je
te fais des crochepatttes pour être le
premier en école de médecine, je te
donne pas les cours ou je te je te fais
des des croches-pieds quand je vais
vendre les sous-marins et et je te crée
un climat de guerre économique qui crée
des chômeurs chez toi parce que un
chômeur ça coûte plus cher qu'un mort.
Donc je vais te plomber ton économie. ce
changement à
180° de cet immense bateau que tu peux à
la fois contempler à l'échelle des
individus et contempler à l'échelle des
États. Si tu fais ton virage, les autres
ils vont te
bouffer. Je n'en suis pas
sûr. Gandy n'a pas entendu que les
Britanniques s'en aillent à Reculon en
s'excusant d'avoir colonisé l'Inde.
Gandhi a simplement dit, "Vous êtes pas
chez vous, c'est pas juste et on va
faire en sorte que ça devienne
ingouvernable comme ça vous allez
partir." Je crois profondément à la
puissance de la nonvolence si elle est
généralisée et que tout le monde a cette
posture là. Et on n plus dans le jeu de
la partie de gourdin ou du repli dans la
grotte. On entre dans le fait qu'on
s'assoit pour se parler et trouver des
points de rencontre. On revient au fait
que la rencontre et le prendre soin de
la qualité de lien est l'enjeu de la
décennie et en tout cas du siècle. Tu as
déjà interagi avec une intelligence
artificielle ? Non, jamais. Non, du
tout. J'en ai vu faire par des amis
autour. Moi, j'ai pas envie de jouer à
ça, mais je j'ai vu se composer des
poèmes, une dissertation sur un sujet
philosophique et c'est effectivement
impressionnant.
Qu'est-ce que tu en penses
de nouveau ? Tu as 3h pour qu'on en
parle. H bah ça fait 1h18 1h 1h18
d'interview et 38 secondes donc il te
reste 2h.
Bien sûr que j'ai des appréhensions. Euh
tu vas parle parle-nous de tes
appréhensions. Jusqu'ici, j'ai tellement
la conscience que le propre de l'humain,
c'est d'avoir un génie, une intuition,
une une sagesse, une capacité à
percevoir des choses subtiles qui n'a
pas du tout été exploré. On a toute
petite partie de notre conscience est
explorée et c'est hallucinant que avec
cette petite partie de conscience, on a
délégué la faculté de penser à une
machine alors qu'on sait rien de soi.
C'est juste invraisemblable, tu vois. Et
on va alors la caricature c'est c'est
Mus qui veut aller sur sur Mars.
Qu'est-ce qu'on connait caricature ? Bah
la caricature c'est d'aller plus loin au
lieu de rester là. C'est ça. Faut bien
vendre du rêve pour faire de
l'exploitation d'astéroïdes en
orbitation autour de la planète. On
envoyé des stars dans
des c'est c'est un plan de com. Oui,
c'est un plan de com.
Ouais, bien sûr. Mais la simple idée
d'aller voir ailleurs, ça ça fascine
certainement les les ça donne de
l'espoir. Bah quel espoir il y a-t-il ça
permet de lever des capitaux ? Bah
peut-être pour des gens qui sont dans le
business ou ou en souffrance à la avec
trop de business. Ben clairement en vie
d'intérieur sidéral. C'est intéressant
de se dire tiens, il veut aller voir le
vie d'intersidéral. Alors que alors je
veux pas critiquer l'humain bien sûr,
mais avoir ce type de projet et cette
avidité à accumuler des ressources euh
ça fait certainement preuve d'une grande
intelligence du business et on peut lui
laisser ça certainement. Mais mon dieu,
si on est un être profondément heureux,
tendre, délicat et en trouver une
expansion joyeuse, est-ce que l'on va
chercher à accaparer, à acheter ? Je
sais pas, je pense pas. Je pense pas. Il
y a quelque chose de de
d'excessif qui de démesuré. On parle
d'ubris
véritablement manifesté là-dedans. Et il
y a quelque chose même de de violent
parce que aller polluer la planète pour
s'envoyer se faire envoyer une Tesla sur
orbite. Mais c'est c'est à l'époque que
nous vivons, c'est c'est cinglant comme
maltraitance de la planète et de la
conscience humaine de faire un geste
pareil. J'ai envie de de
de partager mon expérience. Ça fait plus
de 30 ans que j'accompagne des personnes
qui sont pris dans des mécanismes
violents. Violence subtile, brutalité
ordinaire, système de pensée
assombrissant, divisant, culpabilité et
cetera. Donc je pense pouvoir partager
mon expérience
dans qui contredit ce que la psychologie
traditionnelle dit selon laquelle
l'homme serait violent par nature.
L'homme est un loup pour l'homme, autre
formule latine, je n'y crois pas du
tout. latin euh au mot omiloupous est
est oui peut-être mais au mot
ominiloupous on peut se passer du verbe
je pense dans le latin
classique. Et
bien euh je ne crois pas à ça. Plus
j'observe la violence plus je vois que
la violence n'est pas le reflet de notre
nature du tout.
La violence et le refrait de la
frustration ou l'expression de la
frustration de nature. C'est quand notre
nature est frustrée que nous sommes
violents. Et les gens qui nous écoutent
pourront certainement le reconnaître.
Quand mon besoin de reconnaissance n'est
pas nourri, je peux être violent. Quand
mon besoin d'être écouté n'est pas
nourri. Quand mon besoin d'être compris
n'est pas nourri, je pourrais être
violent. Quand mon besoin d'avoir ma
place, de trouver du sens à ma vie n'est
pas nourri, à ce moment-là, je peux être
violent. Nous pouvons tous être
violents. Qui n'a pas eu envie de
hausser le ton ou d'envoyer une baffe à
la figure de l'autre ? Si nous ne
comprenons pas, si nous ne respectons
pas notre nature, nous pouvons tous être
violents. D'où l'urgence à apprendre à
connaître sa nature pour trouver le
discernement et le vocabulaire pour
nommer ce qui se passe en soi et éviter
l'effet cocôte minute ou l'effet
mécanisme compensatoire grandiloquant à
la Elon Musk. Est-ce que tu as déjà eu
des conduites introspectives extrêmes,
c'est-à-dire est-ce que tu t'es déjà mis
dans un état psychologique pour
comprendre l'autre ? Par exemple,
comprendre quelqu'un qui fait une greffe
de la fin. Est-ce que tu es passé par le
chemin des autres pour essayer de
comprendre l'autre
? Je fais que ça dans mon métier. Tu as
déjà fait une graphe de la fin ? Non,
mais je veux dire comprendre l'autre,
rejoindre l'autre là où il est, c'est un
des exercices d'empathie profonde que je
pratique, je vais pas dire tous les
jours, mais dans toutes les formations
que que j'accompagne. Combien de temps
tu tiens sans manger ? Ça je sais
combien de temps tu tiens sans manger si
je me souviens et et tout en gardant ton
calme ?
Euh je comprends ma
question. Si je te mets en pénurie de
ressources Oui. Au bout de combien de
temps tu vas arrêter de jacter ? On va
s'aimer, on va se faire des bisous sur
la bouche, on va se connaître, ça va
être super
bien. J'arrive pas à t'énerver, c'est
profondément énervant.
Mais pourquoi est-ce que ça m'énerverait
? me poser questions qui sont censées.
Il se fait que j'ai pas eu l'occasion de
de
de jeûer autrement que en ayant fait le
choix par santé, par moment, par
chrétienté. Ah non, pas par chrétienté.
Non non non non, je fais pas carême.
Non, je je respecte profondément les
gens qui font ça et il y a quelque chose
de très beau dans ce rituel mais je ne
le pratique pas.
Non, j'ai juste appris à l'armée dans
l'entraînement de paracommando que l'on
peut passer une semaine en ne dormant
que 8h pour toute la semaine. Ça, j'ai
appris la résistance incroyable et ça ça
a fondé en moi. C'est pour ça que
c'était tellement bête de balancer le
service militaire comme ça sans le
transformer par un service civil pour
avoir des occasions de dépassement de
soi. Moi, ce service militaire a fondé
en moi la confiance incroyable que nous
avons un pouvoir de nous transformer
aussi considérable qu'ignorer. Comme je
l'ai rappelé il y a peu de temps, c'est
extraordinaire. On se connaît pas, on
est en surface de soi, on est là à
clapoter avec les émotions, l'action,
réaction, l'actualité, les Nous avons
besoin d'apprendre à descendre
profondément dans un courant de fond qui
est au cœur de chacun de nous et dont
nous parle toutes les traditions. De
nouveau avec des mots très convergents,
le mot de souffle qu'on a déjà évoqué
très souvent là. Retrouvez votre souffle
profond, retrouvez votre nappe
fréatique, retrouver le le l'essence de
votre être. travaille à toutes sortes de
mots pour dire ça et je crois que c'est
l'enjeu essentiel de notre époque, c'est
d'apprendre à trouver ça. Tu peux
m'expliquer les grriis que tu portes ?
Qu'est-ce que tu appelles gris ? Des
bagues, tes colliers. C'est c'est des
C'est quoi ? Tu m'expli alors après.
Oui, je sais pas si tu veux.
Euh, qu'est-ce que c'est ? C'est des des
cadeaux de ma tendre épouse. Et ça c'est
un cadeau que je me suis offert. J'ai un
bracelet là que j'ai trouvé dans une Non
non. C'est des objets que je trouve
beau. Ça t'aide à te rappeler des choses
ou simplement par beauté ? Oui, le le
plaisir. J'en ai plusieurs, je change.
Je trouve
que la vie est faite pour être savouré
et embelléli.
Tout converge dans la nature. On est en
plein printemps ici. Le moindre arbre
essaie d'être magnifique, de répandre
ses fleurs. La moindre fougère essaie de
se dérouler la façon la plus gracieuse.
Le moindre cheveuil saute le fossé de la
façon la plus élégante. Le moindre Milan
vole avec grâce dans l'évolu du ciel.
Mais oui, évidemment. Et embellir le
monde. Je comprends pas que les gens
s'habillent tristement ou à forcerie
avec des habits déchirés. C'est c'est
une insulte à l'humanité que de porter
des habits déchirés. Mais parce que
franchement j'ai pu voyager et
rencontrer des gens qui sont dans des
vêtements déchirés et qui rêveraient
d'avoir des habits propres. Alors nous
société Nanti, on va faire fabriquer
chez de grandes marques des habits
déchirés. Mais à quoi on joue ? Je suis
très scandalisé par ça effectivement.
répondre à ta question mais Grégri la
vanité du temps qui passe. Ah oui et ça
porte un nom les têtes de
Morm je sais plus quoi.
Revenons revenons à à notre symbolique
de
société si avancée mais à la fois si
retardée. Comment on fait pour
réconcilier selon toi le nord avec le
sud
? Il semble qu'il soit pas si éloigné
que
ça. Je le sors d'un livre que je
recommanderai d'ailleurs, Fullness de
Hans
Rossling.
Faxfulness, un livre, c'est un
chercheur, médecin, responsable et
chercheur en santé mondiale
internationale qui a énormément voyagé à
travers le monde. Et ce livre
extrêmement intéressant pour nous
inviter à faire attention au fait. Nous
sommes souvent pris dans des systèmes de
pensées qui datent et qui continuent à
voir le monde dans la division, les pays
développés, les pays sous-développés
notamment, c'est un des exemples qu'il
donne. Ça n'est pas du tout aussi
binaire que ça et mais diffuse le monde
plutôt en quatre catégories. Ceux qui
ont moins de 2 € ceux qui ont moins de 5
€ ceux qui ont moins de 20 € et ceux qui
ont autour de 65 € par jour et plus. Et
là ça met tout d'un coup la conscience
que 75 pardon c'est du belge 75 %
c'était mon bou le belge. Le Suisse
aussi c'est pas mal. C'est pas mal hein.
Donc 75 % de la population euh vit dans
des pays à revenu moyen. 75 % de la
population, c'est une bonne nouvelle qui
n'est pas répandue. On continu à croire
que mais il y a évidemment encore des
tragédies et beaucoup de pays qu'il faut
aider. On est parfaitement conscient de
ça. Mais ce livre Fafulness est une
invitation à regarder le verre à moitié
plein plutôt qu'à moitié vide. C'est
précieux. Si je te dis une calorie
assimilée représente 10 calories
fossiles. Si je te
dis nous produisons 104 millions de
barils de pétrole par jour la
terre et on produit 300 l'équivalent
baril de 300 millions de barils de dette
par
jour. Tu comprends ce que je veux te
dire ?
J'ai le vertige quand j'entends ça.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que ce sont des chiffres qui
dépassent mon entendement de simples
citoyen qui qui compte ses petits enfin
ses sous de façon modeste et qui essaie
de maintenir son un équilibre pour euh
assurer sa vie normale. Et donc tout
d'un coup, ce genre de de montant, ça
dépasse mon entendement. Et
je réalise
que il y a un dérèglement dans la façon
de gérer la maison humaine
quoi. Chaque père ou mère de famille qui
gère son budget est attentif à assurer
des rentrées qui correspondent aux
dépenses et pas inverser les choses.
Quand la douce musique de la dette va
s'arrêter, est-ce que tu penses que les
graines des démons que le capitalisme ou
la la société a planté à grande échelle
dans la tête de ses oailles par ses
souffrances, le fait de pas s'écouter ?
Est-ce que tu penses que on va pas se
retrouver avec des gens qui vont se
matérialiser en
démon du jour au lendemain quand la
musique va s'arrêter ? Quand tu vois
quand il y a une grande tempête, on dit
toujours que les gens coopèrent mais au
bout de 3 jours, ils coopèrent un peu
moins. Mais quand tu vois que quand on
annonce un confinement, les gens se
précipitent, se marchent dessus,
prennent n'importe
quoi.
L'égoïsme va se rematérialiser. Comment
on fait pour avoir des mesures
proactives pour éviter que les gens si
la musique s'arrête ou s'il y a une
grosse tempête ou s'il y a une grosse
guerre pour éviter que les gens ne
redeviennent pas égoïstes
? Il faut faire quoi
quand tu évoques le fait de en cas de
confinement de de d'aller faire ces ces
achats de façon compulsive, je serais
juste intéressé à connaître la
proportion de la population qui a fait
ça et il y en a on en a vu. Mais quelle
est la proportion ? Je suis pas sûr que
ce soit si majeur que ça. Franchement
pas sûr vraiment. Et donc ce serait
intéressant de nouveau fuckness, le
titre du bouquin dont je vous parle, de
cadrer ça pour ne pas de nouveau très le
goût du drame et en remettre une couche
quoi. Je plutôt un émerveillement moi
pour qui travaille avec les gens en cœur
à cœur et souvent à cœur ouvert de
réaliser la générosité qu' a le cœur de
chatin, l'empathie et le le la le besoin
de prendre soin, de chérir, de donner de
soi. Et d'ailleurs, c'est souvent pour
beaucoup d'êtres humains une souffrance
de sentir. Il y a en moins un trésor
d'amour qui voudrait se donner, se
distribuer joyeusement, mais j'ai peur
d'être mal pris. J'ai peur d'être
interprété malheureusement. J'ai peur de
m'offrir ça au mauvais endroit. Et donc
beaucoup de gens retiennent une
provision d'amour qui les habitent. Mais
nous avons absolument besoin d'apprendre
à utiliser ça et donc à à lâcher ces ces
ces anciens comportements. Tu parlais de
facultés de médecine dans lesquelles on
se fait harceler ou bien on on fait des
croch voilà que l'autre avance et
cetera. Mais est-ce qu'on veut vivre
comme ça ? Est-ce qu'il est pas temps
profondément de changer le monde ? Alors
ça commence peut-être par une vision que
certains qualiféront duque. J'aime
coopératif. Bah oui complètement. Et si
je me souviens d'une collaboratif
convial, si je me souviens de quelques
notions de grec, Utopia pourrait se être
avoir une étymologie comme dire un autre
lieu Top le lieu Utopia un lieu plus
loin. Il y a bien un sujet aujourd'hui
c'est d'aller plus loin. Moi, je suis
ravi quand on dis dans une utopie, bien
sûr, je n'aime pas le monde tel qu'il
est aujourd'hui. J'ai besoin qu'on aille
plus loin. Et donc et de construire
cette nouvelle façon d'être ensemble. tu
aimes pas le monde d'aujourd'hui parce
que tu l'as regardé en face sans le
prisme, sans les lunettes roses dans la
dans toute sa dureté. Est-ce que tu
penses que s'anesthésier en regardant
des petites vidéos de chat, des trucs
gentils, des séries, ne pas voir les
choses telles qu'elles sont ? Tu dis que
tu as voyagé dans des pays où les gens
sont guis et où ils rêveraient
d'avoir des vêtements propres. Oui. Nos
sociétés ou de l'eau propre. Ah ouais.
Oui. Est-ce que tu penses pas que nos
sociétés maintiennent les populations
dans un doux rêve franchement loin de la
réalité ? Ouais, c'est un risque énorme.
Bien sûr, du pain et des jeux. Scroller
sur internet, abonnez-vous à Netflix et
surtout dans ou à autre chose. Oui,
pardon. Ou à autre chose. Abonnez-vous à
quoi à quoi que vous voulez, mais
surtout ne ne réfléchissez pas.
Abonnez-vous à Syerview. D'ailleurs,
vous cliquez sur la petite cloche.
N'oubliez pas de nous soutenir sur Tipi
parce que sans vous, on peut rien faire
et comme on veut pas de l'argent de
Google et ben sans vous, ça va être
compliqué. N'hésitez pas à nous
soutenir. Vas-y, continue. Pas mal la
transition quand même. Transition était
pas mal. Tu as saisi la perche. Bravo.
Mais bien sûr que c'est ça qui qui
s'agit de faire, c'est d'éveiller à
l'esprit critique, au
discernement, à la conscience de la
dignité humaine. On n'est pas là pour Tu
penses que tout le monde peut faire ça ?
l'esprit
critique. Alors de nouveau la
performance tout le monde peut-être pas
mais une grande proportion de la
population tu me diras pas de chiffre
vague ah j'ai pas la capacité ça j'ai
l'impression d'avoir Vilni devant moi.
Une grande partie de la population peut
discerner beaucoup mieux qu'elle ne le
fait si elle s'assoit un peu avec ces
questions là. Il faut pour avoir les
bonnes réponses, ça demande qu'on se
pose les bonnes questions. C'est aussi
simple que ça. L'important, c'est la
question ou la réponse ?
Garder la question
ouverte le plus finement possible.
Garder le
questionnement. Garder ce ce
[Musique]
questionnement que pas mal de traditions
spirituelles résument à qui suis-je ?
Qui suis-je vraiment ? Qui suis-je
vraiment vraiment ? Quel est le sens de
la vie ? Qu'est-ce que la vie qui m'a
mis
là me souhaite ? Moi peut-être j'ai pas
désiré d'être là, mais il seit que la
vie m'a mis là. Ma vie m'a voulu là.
C'est une petite formule que j'utilise
souvent parce qu'elle est je lis comme
une petite chanson. La vie m'a voulu là
et j'invite les personnes qui sont là et
qui seraient dans le doute à
régulièrement se dire s'asseoir sur un
banc, contempler un cerisien en fleurs,
humer les lilas et se dire "La vie m'a
voulu là. Qu'est-ce que la vie veut pour
moi ?" C'est ce questionnement intime
fin qui attire petit à petit les bonnes
réponses. C'est pour ça qu'il y a pas
juste une bonne réponse, il y a un
foisonnement, il y a un caleidoscope de
possibilités à trouver le le
tressaillement qui fait que ah ça, j'ai
envie de vivre, par là, j'ai envie
d'aller, voilà quelque chose que je
voudrais suivre. C'est comme ça qu'on
met en en mouvement le changement de
vie. C'est comme ça que on sort notre
boussole intérieure de sa rouille. Elle
s'est rouillée par des systèmes de
pensées dont j'ai rappelé tout à l'heure
que je l'appelle souvent souvent des
enfermements. Je suis enfermé dans un
système de pensée. Je dérouille ma
boussole pour que petit à petit de
nouveau, elle me donne mon or, mon or à
moi. Par où moi j'ai envie d'aller ?
Qu'est-ce qui a un sens personnel pas
copier-collé et
vivant, pas asceptisé, pas conditionné.
Un sens personnel est vivant. Je crois
que ce discernement, il est au cœur de
notre dignité d'être humain et que je
souhaiterais que les systèmes scolairire
éducatif encourage ça. Malheureusement,
je l'ai évoqué très brièvement. Nous
avons créé une laïcité asphyxiante s'il
était évidemment indispensable de
séparer l'église de l'État. Ça, on est
complètement d'accord. On revient pas
là-dessus. Et bien, il s'agissait pas
d'abandonner toute vie intérieure. La
laïcité, à mes yeux en tout cas, ce
n'est pas l'abandon de la vie
intérieure. La laïcité, c'est le
côtoiement fécond et profondément
respectueux de toutes les formes de vie
intérieure. Mais ça suppose que nous
ayons des clés pour ça et que si on n'
pas une pratique religieuse,
l'enseignement permet de de de donner
des des occasions de découvrir c'est
quoi la vie intérieure. Comment est-ce
qu'on entre dans ce cet égrégore de de
ressourcement qui est la vie intérieure
? C'est fondamental pour le vivre
ensemble. Notre vie intérieure ne
concerne pas que nous. Elle commande et
même féconde notre vie sociale parce que
sans vie intérieure, nous sommes
prisonniers de l'ego et ça donne la
catastrophe à laquelle on assiste
aujourd'hui sur le plan politique.
Et tu penses qu'il y aura une conduite
introspective de la de la classe
politique où est-ce qu'on va être obligé
nous français de repasser par nos
vieilles traditions barbares et
archaïques ?
De
nouveau, j'espère une
évolution. On a parlé de Mandela.
Quand j'écrivais il y a 15 ans un
bouquin qui s'appelle du jeu ou nous
combien en travaillant sur le jeu, je
sers le nous et le sous-titre c'est
l'intériorité citoyenne, le meilleur de
soi au service de tous. Je développe
cette notion d'intériorité, donc de vie
intérieure que j'ai appelé intériorité
citoyenne parce qu'elle a cette
dimension citoyenne. Dans ce bouquin-là,
euh en écrivant ce livre, je relis des
textes et je relis sur euh Mandela, sur
Vaclavel, le président de l'ex
Tchécoslovaquie, sur Gandhi et sur Matin
Luther King qui sont et Christin Mourti
aussi. Oui. Oui. Mais ça ça c'est plutôt
sur sur la dimension d'une spiritualité
élargie, mais sur le plan des
changements socio-politiques, les quatre
premiers euh m'ont impressionné parce
qu'ils ont réussi des transformations
sociop-politiques considérables et
inimaginables quelques années auparavant
de façon non violente. Et si on observe
leur parcours, Mandela, Vaclavel, Gandy,
Martin Lutherking, ils ont tous
travaillé leur vie intérieure. Ils ont
tous pris du recul notamment à
l'occasion d'emprisonnement. Bandela 33
ans, Faclavel une dizaine d'années,
Gandhi 8 ans si je me souviens. Enfin
bon, une des occasions de travailler à
affiner qui suis-je, qui suis-je
vraiment ? Qui suis-je vraiment ? V
vraiment quel est le sens de la vie ? En
sorte que quand ces garsl sortent de
prison et se retrouvent à avoir une
certaine aura. En tout cas, Manela
devient président, Eva Lavavel devient
président de l'exchécoslovaquie aussi
alors qu'il avait été en ils avaient été
tous les deux condamnés à la prison. Et
bien, il retrouve les gens Mandela
retrouve les magistrats qu'il avait euh
mis en prison. Non, pour être dans l'ego
en disant "Vous allez payer parce que
c'est moi le patron maintenant, mais au
contraire vous allez m'aider à sortir le
pays de la part, j'ai besoin de vous."
Et de l'autre côté Vlavavel retrouve la
nomenclatour soviétique. Enfin, les gens
qui étaient autrefois sous la
nomenclatura soviétique non pas de
nouveau pour faire une querelle d'ego en
disant je vais vous faire souffrir parce
que vous m'avez souffrit. On n plus dans
l'ego, mon dieu, on est dans l'être en
expansion, en ouverture. On va servir le
pays. On va sortir l'extoslovaquie du
marasme soviétique. Et c'est ce travail
d'intériorité au service de l'action
sociale qui a besoin d'être compris
aujourd'hui par de plus en plus de
personnes. Nous avons besoin de notre
vie intérieure pour changer le monde.
Qu'est-ce que tu peux me dire sur
Krishna Murti ?
que depuis que j'ai découvert ce
contemporain parce qu'il est décédé il y
a pas si longtemps, je suis très inspiré
par une partie de son
travail, cette conscience de la dignité
profonde de l'être humain, de son
essence
spirituelle. Il y a un aspect un peu
austère dans sa pensée qui ne donne
correspond pas vraiment à mon goût de
vivre. Je suis un bon belge qui aime la
vie profondément et qui a besoin de
profiter du fait d'être incarné dans une
chair qui a ses cinq sens et qui a le
goût de la vivre. Toutefois, sur le plan
de la de la guidance, de l'inspiration,
du de la piste, je suis touché par les
messages qu'il nous transmet
certainement. Comment toi tu fais pour
gérer le doute ?
Je côtoie des gens qui ont côtoyé le
doute et qui en ont fait quelque chose.
Je lis de la sagesse comme Christin
Mourti et bien d'autres. Je lis de la
poésie. Je lis des gens qui se sont
interrogés, qui se sont posés des
questions, qui ont laissé venir des
possibles réponses, qui se sont laissés
inspirer par toutes les manifestations
de ce que les traditions appellent le
souffle. Je je côtoie ça dans mes
lectures. Moi-même, je me laisse
inspirer comme ça. Je prends
régulièrement des moments de
vacuité ou pour laisser quelque chose me
traverser et je trouve ça extrêmement
inspirant. Je prépare mes conférences
comme ça. Je je travaille mon livre
comme ça. Je me prépare à animer un
séminaire résidentiel de 5 jours avec
des personnes qui travaillent souvent
des difficultés et donc j'ai besoin
d'être bien ancré à l'intime de moi. Je
peux pas être là dans l'émotionnel. J'ai
besoin d'être profondément dans ce
courant de fond dont je parlais à
l'instant. Et ça c'est dans nos mains.
Nous avons ça dans nos mains. Tu as déjà
tu as déjà pris de la drogue de chaman ?
Non, j'ai jamais goûté à ma moindre
drogue. J'ai l'amour quand même. À
l'amour, c'est pas une
drogue. Oui, bien sûr que je suis grisé
d'amour.
Question internet. Monsieur Dansembourg
étant chrétien, je me permets deux
points. Quelle est son opinion des coup
de fouet du Christ au marchand du temple
et quel parallèle peut-il faire sur la
légitimité de la violence dans l'espace
public
? Vaste question.
Bon courage.
Oui. En tout cas, la première leçon
qu'on en tire, c'est qu'il peut y avoir
de saintes colères et nous allons donc
pouvoir évoquer le fait
que si j'enseigne depuis des années, la
non violence, ça ne veut pas dire la non
colère ni la non vigueur. Beaucoup de
confusion. Beaucoup de gens pensent que
la non violence, c'est un truc
bisounours pour fumeur de pétard, peace
and love et tout le monde va bien. C'est
pas du tout ça. C'est vigoureux. Et donc
euh apprendre à bien formuler ses
colères au bon moment et à la bonne
personne, c'est une discipline, c'est
une hygiène. Et donc je vois dans cette
image du Christ le fait que même si cet
être euh symbolise la nonvolence et
l'amour, il est fâché, il est en colère
et il indique qu'il y a des limites et
il le fait très très clairement par ce
geste-là. À quoi ça correspond dans la
vie quotidienne ? Ben, je me suis formé
avec Marchal Rosenberg qui était
lui-même très très proche du travail de
Gandhi qui euh nous disait Gandy, s'il
fallait choisir entre la lâcheté
et
la force, je choisirai la
force parce que la l'acheter, c'est pas
possible. Et donc
euh
Marchallenberg paravrasait cette formule
en disant "Nous avons le pouvoir
d'utiliser la force protectrice." Et
c'est clair que si tout à l'heure en
sortant dans le bouvoir je me fais
agresser par quelqu'un, je vais lui
balancer si je peux un coup de point ou
un coup de pied pour essayer de me
protéger. C'est pas pour l'attaquer,
c'est pas pour le meurtrir mais si c'est
la seule façon de me défaire d'un coup
qui pourrait me porter atteinte, je le
ferai. Usage de la force protectrice.
Mais au-delà de ça, s'il est par terre,
je vais dire "Mais pourquoi tu m'as
frappé ?" et je vais essayer d'aller
voir une conversation avec lui.
Tu vas te prendre trois coups de couteau
puis on va pas en reparler. C'est
possible. Mais vous savez, tu sais,
c'est c'est c'est surprenant quand tu te
fais agresser de voir stop, pourquoi tu
me parles comme ça ? Et d'être là,
d'être là bien droit. Ça c'est la force
de la nonvolence qui est souvent mal
considérée. Bien des gens pensent de
nouveau que c'est un truc douceux,
gentil. Ça n'a juste rien à voir avec
ça. Moi, j'ai appris à me mettre en
colère grâce à la non violence. Avant,
j'étais trop gentil et je disais je suis
un peu contrarié mais c'est pas grave,
ça me dérange un peu, mais faites que
vous voulez. Et j'étais pas en colère.
Maintenant, je sais faire des colères
extrêmement claires mais non violentes
parce que je n'accuse personne, je
critique pas mais je dis mon point.
Comment tu fais pour gérer les gens
passifs agressifs ?
Il faudrait un
exemple. Ah, il y en a plein d'avant.
Euh de nouveau, je je perçois que le
fait de savoir avoir de l'empathie pour
une attitude permet souvent à la
personne de changer sa technique ou sa
tactique. Et l'agressivité est
l'expression d'un mal-être. Si j'arrive
à me rejoindre au mal-être, la personne
cesse d'être agressive.
Question internet. Comment la
communication non violente permet-t-elle
de désamorcer un conflit sans
compromettre ses besoins
? Ben, ça rejoint la question
précédente. Si quelqu'un m'interpelle
vigoureusement en me disant "Tu es un
égoïste, tu penses qu'à toi." Autrefois,
dans un système violent, gourdin ou
grotte, j'aurais pu répondre "Égoïste
toi-même, tu as vu comment tu me parles
?" Et ça, c'est la vieille façon de
résoudre les conflits par l'agressivité.
On est fatigué de ça. On a besoin
d'autre chose. Donc quand la personne
m'envoie sa petite phrase, "Tozoglis, tu
penses qu'à toi." Petit moment
d'autoempathie avec une intériorité bien
huilée. C'est pas le moment de commencer
à essayer de savoir ce qui se passe en
moi. J'ai besoin de savoir rapidement,
je n'aime pas qu'on me parle sur ce ton.
J'ai envie d'envoyer mon point dans la
gueule de l'autre. Mais c'est pas comme
ça que j'ai envie de résoudre les
conflits. J'ai besoin de comprendre
pourquoi il me parle comme ça. Moi, si
j'ai envie de traiter quelqu'un
d'égoïste et que je me sens triste tout
seul. Ah ben oui, c'est vrai. Et et ça
veut dire que j'ai besoin de ben
d'écoute ou d'attention. Ah ben oui, en
comprenant l'humain en moi, parce que je
me pratique régulièrement, j'ai quelques
clés pour comprendre l'humain à l'autre.
Tout ça en une fraction de seconde parce
que l'autre il est là, hein. Et donc je
peux assez rapidement ayant cette ce
réflexe d'autoempathie, quand l'autre me
balance sa phrase "Assassine, tu es un
égoïste, tu penses qu'à toi, est-ce que
tu es en colère parce que tu aurais
besoin d'attention ?" Non, tu m'écoutes
jamais. Ah donc tu aurais besoin
d'écoute ? Oui. Et ben je t'écoute.
Assi-toi. Et en trois phrases
d'empathie, on est allé voir ce qui se
passe sur la colline de l'autre. C'est
l'expression qu'on emploie souvent en
communication novembre. Je suis sur une
colline, l'autre est sur une colline, on
va essayer de voir qu'est-ce que toi tu
vis, pourquoi tu me parles comme ça ? Et
ça demande, vous l'aurez perçu et les
auditeurs, je l'espère nous l'auront
perçu. Ça c'est de la non violence 7è
dane. Parce qu' évidemment que l'envie
de répondre du tac au tac là la surface
elle est là mais c'est plus là qu'on
veut résoudre les enjeux du monde. On a
besoin de descendre à l'intérieur. OK.
Une fois une fois que tu as analysé en
une fraction de seconde les faiblesses
de l'autre, les failles et ce qu'il
déclenche,
je me garderai bien de juger que ce sont
des faiblesses et des failles. C'est
simplement qu'il vit des choses
inconfortables et qu'il a des besoins
qui n'ont pas été entendus. Une fois que
tu as compris que son problème était
inextricable, qu'est-ce que tu fais
? Je me garderai également de la
croyance que le problème de l'autre est
inextricable.
À force d'avoir expriqué beaucoup de
souffrances humaines, je sens que j'ai
quelques clés pour aider la personne à
mieux se comprendre. Et c'est ça qui
devrait être appris. Il y a pas beaucoup
d'enjeux humains inextricables mais
quand on pige rien à l'humain, on les
trouve vite inextricables évidemment. Et
alors on entend on ressort le gourdin ou
la grotte. Mais c'est ça l'éducation. Ah
ou alors je m'en fous quoi.
L'indifférence. Ben oui, c'est un peu la
grotte. Faut-moi la paix
quoi. Est-ce que ça a répondu à la
question des besoins ? Oui. Alors
question que je prends à la volée.
Thomas a-t-il un truc pour identifier
une personne qui cache son jeu en
amitié, amour et pouvoir et pouvoir
détecter avant de s'engager pour
l'interrogation. Ça marche aussi pour
savoir ce qui ne va pas chez soi. Point
d'interrogation. Est-ce que Est-ce que
tu tu as un truc pour détecter les
sociopathes ? C'est ça l'idée. Un
capteur particulier. Ben non, j'ai pas
un truc
particulier. Ce que je crois que nous
pouvons développer, c'est une
sensibilité au signe éventuel
d'incohérence. Qu'est-ce qui me donne
une impression d'incohérence ? et de
pouvoir le cas échéant rendre ça
visible, indiquer tiens tu me dis ça
alors que tu agis comme ça qu'est-ce qui
se passe en toi et indiquer et donc de
nouveau c'est vigoureux de pouvoir faire
ça de pouvoir dire par exemple si on a à
faire un manager à combien de fois les
gens se plainent d'avoir un manager dont
il considère qu'il pourrait être dans
une
attitude de de pervers narcissique ça
arrive quand même assez souvent ce
cliché et bien de pouvoir confondre
autant que possible la personne ses
viigu de pouvoir dire "Je suis pas
d'accord avec votre façon de faire. Vous
nous dites ceci mais vous agissez comme
ça. Comment expliquez-vous ?" Paf et
j'indique mon point. Quand ton point il
est pas écouté et que par exemple tu
parlais tu comprends pourquoi je te pose
cette question ? C'est que le
politique je dirais que alors c'est une
suputation mais il doit y avoir une
belle concentration de perverse
narcissique dans cette caste. Euh euh il
ils font de temps en temps des des
manœuvres dilatoires de "Oui oui,
faites-nous des cahiers de doléance."
Oui oui, on va faire des réunion euh
faites-nous une convention citoyenne et
puis on s'en foutra après. Ouais ouais.
Comment on fait en tant que
population face à ça ? Ce ce manque
d'écoute
ben on le voit, on manifeste manifeste
comment des LBD 40 en pleine tête.
C'est là que notre système est
complètement obsolète en votant pour tel
président ou tel gouvernement une fois
tous les 5 ans ou tous les 4 ans, on
donne une sorte de chèque en blanc et
puis on laisse partir. Il s'agirait
d'inventer un mode de concertation
régulière. Moi, j'étais frappé de voir
l'absence complète de nos gouvernements
des enjeux de systémie. Comment est-ce
que la montée des gilets jaunes avec des
manifestations très violentes qu'on peut
en partie comprendre et qui sont en
partie légitime bien sûr, mais qui sont
quand même extrêmement violente et
destructrice, comment est-ce que cette
montée émotionnelle n'a pas été perçue ?
Comment est-ce que les gouvernements
n'ont pas des capteurs fins pour
réaliser est-ce que la population
comprend ce qui se passe ? Est-ce qu'ils
sont ré ce qui se passe ? Est-ce qu'ils
voient le sens de nos mesures ? Est-ce
qu'ils peuvent accepter un changement
éventuel ? Comment est-ce qu'il y a pas
des capteurs ? Enfin, c'est une urgence
de développer ça. Et il se fait que je
je j'ai voyagé en en Nouvelle-Calédonie
il y a 2 ans, j'étais invité à donner
des formation là euh et que peu de temps
après, il y a eu le le le les émeutes
parce que tout d'un coup, il y a eu
cette décision du gouvernement français
d'élargir le champ électoral. Enfin, je
rentre pas un peu poussé par des
puissances étrangères. C'est possible.
Enfin, bon, toujours est-il que comment
est-ce qu'on a pas anticipé que ça ne
pouvait que faire des émeutes sanglantes
sur le pays ? Évidemment, comment est-ce
qu'il y a pas de plus de vision ? C'est
là que leur système de d'élection sont
obsolètes et qu'il est temps de mettre
en place un système de concertation
beaucoup plus fine avec des sensibilités
plus délicates et je le soulligne
d'emblé beaucoup plus de femmes au
pouvoir pour
l'intuition pour la conscience de la
systémie. Ça c'est quand même un univers
dans lequel elles ont une réflexion.
L'homme il part tout droit comme ça.
Très souvent par habitude. C'est pas un
gros cliché. C'est quand même assez
souvent que ça se passe. C'est le
contrôle et la commande. On y va à fond
et en force la femme est plus en train
de composer les uns et les autres et on
le voit d'ailleurs, les études le le
montre. Ah, de nouveau je peux pas citer
une référence sans la donner. Allez voir
le programme EV, forum qui a lieu chaque
année dans lequel je suis invité depuis
15 ans à Évian. programme F sur le
leadership féminin. Nombreuses études
cautionnent le fait que quand des femmes
sont au pouvoir dans un comité de
direction et bien à à raison d'au moins
30 à 40 % donc une une certaine densité
quand même, on n'est pas encore à
inverser complètement et bien les
décisions sont beaucoup plus stables et
les chiffres d'affaires beaucoup
meilleurs parce que il y a beaucoup
moins de turnover, il y a plus de
collégialité et c'est juste intéressant
de réaliser que ce que l'on sent que les
valeurs dites féminines, elles sont
partagées par les hommes et les femmes.
Peut-être que jusqu'ici culturellement,
c'est plutôt les valeurs dites
féminines, c'est la la c'est l'empathie,
c'est la convialité, la concertation, la
collégialité, le la tension mutuelle,
c'est ça qui c'est porté par les hommes
aussi hein, mais culturellement c'est
plutôt les femmes qui les portent. Si je
te dis quand les femmes choisiront les
meilleurs d'entre nous, le monde ira
mieux. Ça te fait penser à quoi ? Quand
les femmes choisiront les meilleurs
d'entre nous, le monde ira mieux. Bah
pourquoi pas ? sans faire de stéréotype
mais les moins cupides, les plus dans
l'empathie, tu comprends ce que je Oui.
Oui. Oui.
Tu penses que c'est les femmes qui ont
la clé en fait du bonheur du monde ? En
tout cas, ce sont les valeurs féminines
portées par les hommes et les femmes qui
ont la clé.
J'ai essayé de te piéger, tu t'es bien
débrouillé. Est-ce que tu as un sujet
que tu souhaiterais aborder avec nous ?
Quelque chose qu'on a pas abordé qui te
tient à cœur ?
Ben, on a on fleuré plusieurs fois.
C'est le fait que chacun d'entre nous
soit davantage engagé dans la
transition socioitique écologique que
davantage de personnes
se s'impliquent pour la qualité du monde
qu'elle voudrait avoir que chaque
citoyen se sente responsable de son
petit écosystème. On peut pas changer le
monde et j'ai pas le rêve moi de changer
le monde du tout du tout mais je peux
changer mon monde. Je peux créer là où
je suis avec mon conjoint, ma conjointe,
mes enfants, mon école, mes voisins, ma
famille, ma belle famille. Je peux
apporter la qualité d'écoute de relation
que je rêverai se voir se se diffuser
dans le monde. Avoir envie quand même
parce que quand tu es exposé à des gens
toxiques, le fait de vouloir comprendre
les gens toxiques, tu vas juste
comprendre que c'est des gens toxiques
et tu les laisses gentiment de côté.
Tu les laisses pas de côté. Tu les
laisses pas de côté. Tu leur laisses des
petits cailloux blancs. C'est ça. Oui.
Pour les perdre dans la forêt.
Oui. Mais c'est l'exemple type de pour
leur indiquer où il de quel chemin ils
doivent prendre. Ben par exemple en tout
cas leur partager perd dans la forêt
qu'après
on peut changer personne mais on peut on
peut partager ce qui nous tient à cœur
comment nous avons pu mettre du
changement en place dans notre
existence. on peut témoigner et c'est
vraiment précieux mais effectivement
arrêter de se gendarmer parce que telle
ou telle personne nous agace ou son
comportement nous plaint nous nous
déplaît aller
plutôt affiner approfondir la qualité
des liens avec les gens qu'on rencontre
toute rencontre peut l'occasion d'une
chaleur humaine. On
peut transformer le monde une personne à
la fois au supermarché. Vous pouvez être
énervé parce que vous êtes fatigué, que
la voiture votre voiture est mal garée
et maltraité la caissière qui traite vos
affaires. C'est le choix que vous pouvez
faire et en même temps, vous pouvez
avoir un peu de recul pour dire "Bien
sûr, je suis fatigué, bien sûr, je suis
pressé, bien sûr, elle est plus lente
que ce que j'aurais voulu et j'attends
là." Et en même temps, elle est
fatiguée, on est vendredi soir, elle a
reçu sa journée dernière, elle et avoir
un sourire vers elle et avoir un peu
d'empathie en disant "La journée était
fatigante, vous avez hâte de rentrer
chez vous". Et ça, ça change le monde.
Trois phases de présence. Sais, tu sais
comment on appelle ça nous ? La fonction
exponentielle du bien. Ah bah c'est une
jolie formule exponentielle.
On dit tu aideras trois personnes et tu
transmettras c à ces trois personnes
d'aider encore trois personnes, d'être
gentil, bienveillant à trois personnes.
Ah la fonction exponentielle bien. C'est
contagieux. C'est contagieux et c'est
exponentiel.
Question de Jérémy. Sur quels travaux
scientifiques reposent ces thèses ? Ce
ce ça repose sur quoi ce qu'il dit ?
C'est quoi ses sources ? Tu as été passé
par quel chemin ? Tu as étudié qui ? La
Christin Murti, qui d'autre ? Je me suis
bien gardé d'aller chercher. Je suis en
tout cas je me suis bien gardé d'aller
chercher dans des
livres et dans des Tu as fait une école
de psychothérapie de de psychanalyse de
Non. Tu es diplômé d'une école ? Non.
Non. Important de le dire. Bien sûr, il
y a aucun problème. J'ai aucun problème
à dire ça. J'ai fait des années de
psychanalyse et 6 ans trois fois par
semaine et j'ai suivi de nombreuses
formations sur la connaissance de soi et
l'écoute de l'autre. Je suis devenu
psychothérapeute par la pratique.
C'était encore une façon de faire qui
était possible il y a une trentaine
d'années. C'était à la fois pour le
meilleur parce que les personnes
pouvaient suivre vraiment ce qui leur
tenait à cœur, par où elles allaient
vraiment affiner leur propre sensibilité
pour la mettre au service. Mais ça pu
être effectivement l'occasion pour
certaines personnes de se prétendre
thérapeute beaucoup trop rapidement et
de façon certainement abusive. Donc
c'est bien qu'on a mis un peu
d'organisation
là-dedans, mais ce que je veux
souligner, c'est que je n'ai aucune
connaissance
livresque. Tout ce dont je parle, c'est
de l'expérience, de la pratique, de
l'observation, de l'accompagnement
depuis 30 ans. À côté de ça, j'ai lu des
livres qui me confirment des choses que
j'ai perçu mais je ne voulais pas
apprendre des mécanismes dans des
bouquins et puis essayer de voir est-ce
que ça collecte la réalité. Moi, je suis
vraiment pratico pratique. Je suis parti
avec les gamins de la rue et d'avant ça
avec les gens en conflit dans mon métier
d'avocat à essayer de comprendre
qu'est-ce qui se passe, pourquoi le
conflit est là, qu'est-ce qui pourrait
arranger les choses. Et c'est ça qui
fonde le fait, je crois que ce que je
dis est cohérent, c'est que c'est partie
de la vie et pas de l'intellect. Bien,
on devient plus facilement avocat quand
on a on est passé par le domaine ou le
champ politique. Non, on devient plus
facilement avocat quand on a été
politicien. Non. Ou l'inverse,
le la fonction exponentielle du bien, tu
peux le retrouver dans un film qui
s'appelle Un monde meilleur et et euh on
te le recommande vivement. C'est c'est
c'est pas mal. Je remercie la personne
qui parle de soutien scientifique
serait. Si vous avez une piste et des
budgets pour faire une étude
scientifique sur le bénéfice de
l'approche dont je vous parle ici et qui
en gros s'appelle assez souvent la
communication non violente, je serais
ravi jusqu'ici, je suis absolument
convaincu du bénéfice puisque j'en vois
tous les jours autour de moi et je fais
partie d'un réseau de formateurs et
formatrices à travers la planète qui ne
cessent de voir des bénéfices de cette
approche. Tout pas besoin tu as pas
besoin de te raccrocher aux branches de
tes copains pour te donner du poids.
Juste dire tu as vu les bénéfices
c'était suffisant. Ah ben, j'envoie les
voix tous les jours. Je serai pas là
avec l'enthousiasme que j'ai alors que
j'ai largement passé l'âge de la
retraite si je n'avais pas tous les
jours la confirmation de la pertinence
de ce
travail. Alors, question internet.
Attention euh merci de demander à cet
homme. Je
fais Attends, attends, attends, attends.
C'est un peu mal écrit et j'ai besoin de
rapprocher mes
yeux. Je fais comment pour voir ? C'est
toi qui a envoyé ça ?
Je fais comment pour voir la vie en
positif quand j'ai vécu une enfance
jusqu'à l'âge adulte à la BAM ? Tu tu
sais
que j'ai des troubles mentaux graves à
cause de mon enfance et une maladie
autoimmune forme sévère et grave qui a
mis 20 ans à être diagnostiqué plus une
vie dans un quartier pourri et pour
finir j'ai perdu deux enfants à la
naissance.
Comment on fait pour positiver quand mes
mes D sont pipés dès le départ
? Ben d'abord, merci beaucoup pour cette
question très cruciale et très
authentique
et dans lequel d'autres auditeurs
peuvent certainement se se reconnaître
et qui malheureusement revient
régulièrement dans le travail
d'accompagnement. Comment ce qu'on fait
lorsqu'on a été à ce point marqué par la
souffrance et la justice et la
maltraitance ? tôt et c'est tout un
travail et la réponse risque d'être
sommaire évidemment dans le cadre que
nous avons ici. C'est tout un travail de
démantellement de la souffrance,
démantellement de l'empreinte. Quelque
chose s'est imprimé et pourrait
effectivement vous déprimer. Il est
temps d'apprendre à défaire cette
impression. C'est une partie de vous qui
avez vécu cette tragédie. Ce n'est pas
tout vous. Ce n'est pas tout vous. Une
partie de vous. Est-ce que j'ose dire ça
comme ça sans savoir si vous êtes là, si
vous m'écoutez ? Une partie de vous
intime, très profonde là dans le fond la
na de cette maltraitance et a besoin de
sentir que je peux petit à petit
m'asseoir là-dessus. Et je vous
encourage en tout cas si ce que je vous
dis vous paraît difficile à comprendre,
aller écouter Boris Culnick dans de
nombreuses interventions qu'il fait.
lui-même a perdu ses parents, je pense,
dans dans dans les les camps de
concentration à l'époque et a vécu une
enfance difficile et a écrit un très
beau livre qui s'appelle Un merveilleux
malheur. Comment à travers l'épreuve, on
n'est pas dans un monde dominance, mais
quelque chose peut éclore comme s'il
fallait que certaines coquilles se casse
pour qu'une éclosion se fasse. En tout
cas, c'est l'encouragement que je vous
fais. Ne restez pas dans la sensation
juste d'une vie subie. Je vous encourage
vraiment à faire confiance dans la
pulsion de vie. La vie vous a voulu là.
Le parcours a été tragique. C'est une
chose. Un travail de deuil peut se faire
pour se désimprimer de ça et sentir
qu'une puissance de vie attend des clore
en vous. Voilà. Existe aussi des numéros
pour pouvoir appeler, pour parler, pour
consulter et et recevoir de l'aide en
France. Et pour ce genre de choses, on a
besoin d'aide. C'est difficile soit-même
de s'extirper de ce genre de chos et
donc de pas
s'enrouler dans l'illusion que ce que
j'ai vécu personne ne le comprendra. Et
donc je reste avec ma souffrance et j'y
ai tout. Finalement, c'est moi-même qui
me suis mis des bandelettes comme une
momie. Non, j'ai besoin d'ouvrir ça.
Aller dans des groupes de paroles, des
groupes de personnes qui ont vécu des
traumatismes, des qui ont vécu de
l'abus. Et heureusement qu'il y en a
parce que la parole libère, c'est pas
une formule, c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui ne cesse de m'impressionner
combien nous avons le pouvoir de nous
dégager de souffrance en nommant ce qui
a été si douloureux. Quelque chose
s'évacue, se dissou, ça sèche comme ça
se en en parlant avec des professionnels
et et et et des oui des groupes de
parole, des groupes thérapeutiques et ça
devrait être beaucoup plus connu de
nouveau que ça existe hein ces
choses-là. Thomas, est-ce que tu as
trois livres à conseiller à la
communauté
? Livres qui ont été importants pour toi
? Oui. Et pendant que tu réfléchis, donc
tu ne consultes pas, tu n'es pas
psychologue, tu donnes que des
conférences et tu éc Non non, j'ai j'ai
eu un cabinet de psychothérapeute
pendant 10 ans. J'ai quand même une
pratique clinique d'accompagnement des
personnes pendant 10 ans. Et puis à la
sortie de mon premier livre, c'est des
gentils, soyez vrai, j'ai réalisé que ça
m'amenait des demandes de conférence et
de formation sur cette approche que j'ai
apprise moi-même de Marchal Rosenberg.
qu'on appelle la communication non
violente. Appellation qui est très
réductrice pour je pourrais en dire un
mot juste après parce que l'appellation
ne rend pas compte de la puissance de
qu'il y a derrière ce mot-là. Et donc
euh j'ai effectivement écrit "C'est c
des gentils soyez vrai." C'est mon
premier livre. Euh je sais plus qui est
la question. Si vous voulez que je cite
trois livres qui ont été importants dans
la tr liv la construction de ton être,
de ton raisonnement, de tes pensées.
Oui. Alors, un livre qui a été très très
clarifiant pour moi, c'est le chemin le
moins fréquenté de Scott Pec qui est
très souvent un bon départ pour se
mettre en route et réaliser je suis
fatigué des chemins fréquentés, là où
tout le monde se bouscule, j'ai besoin
de faire mon chemin à ma façon, à
travers la vie. Et ça, c'est un livre
très éclairant. Scotpec, le chemin le
moins fréquenté. Un autre livre qui a
été extrêmement clarifiant pour moi,
c'est le bouquin d'un de Guy Cornau,
psychanalysteien québécois qui par la
suite est devenu mon meilleur ami. Il
est malheureusement décédé il y a
quelques années et son premier livre
qu'il a fait vraiment connaître et
sortir de la consultation individuelle
pour devenir un conférencier et un
formateur et son son livre s'appelle
Père manquant fils manqué. Ce bouquin
m'a absolument bouleversé parce que les
jeunes dont nous nous occupions dans
l'association avaient pratiquement tous
manqué de père, père repère, père en
prison, père absent, père ivrogne, père
fuyant. Et h cet enjeu de la difficulté
à se trouver comme homme dans une
masculinité juste et non pas
caricaturale par la violence ou
complètement démissionnaire était
tellement joliment décrit avec finesse,
avec humanité que j'ai pu rencontrer
Guy. Euh j'ai pu suivre des ateliers
avec lui comme participant dans des
ateliers thérapeutiques. J'ai été
émerveillé par son travail d'accoucheur
de conscience. Une sorte de sage femme
pour sage homme permettant aux êtres
humains de sentir combien ils peuvent se
mettre au monde. C'est vraiment un
travail d'accouchement qui comporte des
convulsions d'ailleurs. C'est pas ce
n'est pas que confortable he c'est loin
sans faut. Mais effectivement c'est la
rencontre avec Guy suite à son livre m'a
décidé à devenir psychothérapeute. Voilà
le deuxième livre. Père manquant fils
manqué.
un bouquin
extrêmement inspirant sur la présence,
l'attention, être là dans ce courant de
fond, c'est le pouvoir de l'instant
présent d'écartoler. Écartoler le
pouvoir de l'instant présent. Vraiment
cette cette simplicité qu'il retrouve à
travers des messages spirituels de tout
temps apprendre à être là, pleinement
là, pas précipité dans le futur, pas
dans le regret du passé, mais dans
l'instant. C'est une force de capacité
d'action et de transition dont je
souhaiterais qu'elle soit davantage
connue. Un conseil pour les jeunes
génération. Tu voulais expliquer le
terme de communication non violente. Ah
oui, je disais à l'instant merci de
revenir là-dessus. C'est vrai que cette
appellation est très pauvre. Lorsqu'on
entend ce mot et moi j'en étais bien des
gens se disent "Mon, je suis pas
violent, j'ai pas besoin de ça. Je suis
très gentil, très doux." Ben, c'est
peut-être précisément parce que tu es
dans des mécanismes de contrainte sur
toi-même que tu ne vois pas. Tellement
de gens se reconnaissent trop gentils.
En tout cas, je reçois tous les jours du
courrier de gens qui me disent "Je me
reconnais tellement dans votre bouquin.
C'est comme si vous l'aviez écrit pour
moi. Vous me donnez des clés pour sortir
de ça." Et mais donc dans cette
appellation communication non violente,
le mot non violente ne plaît pas à tout
le monde, loin sans faux. Et le mot
communication donne l'impression d'un
enjeu uniquement horizontal. Je vais
sans doute apprendre à mieux dire ce que
j'ai à dire et mieux écouter ce que
l'autre a à me à me dire. C'est pas
faux. Il y a une dimension horizontale.
Toutefois, pour apprendre à dire ce que
j'ai à dire, alors ce qui m'habite,
c'est de la colère et plutôt l'image qui
me vient, c'est l'envie d'envoyer mon
point dans la tronche de l'autre et
arriver à trouver les mots pour le dire
avec patience et détermination, l'un
n'empêchant pas l'autre. Et bien ça
c'est de la communication non violente,
7e dane. Et ça demande donc un ancrage
dans qui je suis vraiment. ma vraie
personne au-delà de l'ego et une
certaine capacité d'éveil de conscience
de l'au-delà de l'immédiat de ce que je
vais vivre et de l'autre côté de cette
horizontalité apprendre à écouter
l'autre alors que le ton de l'autre mots
de l'autre l'attitude de l'autre tout
son nonverbal indique que l'autre a
envie d'envoyer son point dans ma figure
à moi et rester disponible empathique
présent patient et déterminé c'est aussi
de la communication non violente 7e dane
et ça demande un ancrage et une sorte de
conscience spirituelle un peu plus
élargie que limite Avant de te poser une
dernière question qui n'est pas une
question, j'ai une question internet. Le
politiquement correct n'est-il pas une
forme d'autocensure pour éviter les
contradictions des dogmes ? La critique
des idéologies passe forcément par une
forme de violence spirituelle et
l'éviter c'est repousser le problème.
À tout niveau, nous avons besoin
d'apprendre à être davantage authentique
et sincère. Le fait de maquiller le
propos, de l'adoucir, de mettre de
l'édulcurant ne nous aide pas à
commencer par la vie de couple. Si je
suis en pétard et que j'ose pas en
parler parce que c'est pas le moment, il
vaudra mieux qu'on en parle plus tard et
puis c'est pas si grave que ça, et bien
mon coup va pas durer. Dans un couple,
s'il y a une tension, on a besoin de
s'en parler. On a besoin d'apprendre à
être vrai et authentique. Dans une
relation au travail, si j'accepte que
mon patron ou ma manager me traite mal
et que j'endure et que j'endure, je vais
finir par faire un bornout. J'ai besoin
d'indiquer mes limites très clairement.
de pouvoir dire "Je ne souhaite pas être
traité comme ça, s'il vous plaît. Est-ce
que vous pouvez l'entendre ? Parce que
franchement sinon je vais prendre
d'autres attitudes et je le je le je le
nomme et je pense que nous avons donc
besoin aussi en politique d'arrêter de
faire en sorte que tout le monde soit
plus ou moins content." Il y a une
expression qui est connue. Il s'agit de
mettre de l'eau dans son vin. Et
qu'est-ce qui arrive quand on met de
l'eau dans son vin ? Tout le monde boit
une mauvaise piquette. Nous avons besoin
d'apprendre à être sincère et de trouver
comment on va partager le vin de l'un ou
le vin de l'autre. mais pas euh
édulcorer la réalité. Et ça ça s'apprend
pour éviter de tomber dans des
mécanismes d'agressivité. Il y a des
gens qui lisent mon titre, cess d'être
gentil, soyez vrai. On dit "Je pas
besoin de ça, moi je suis cache.
Attends." Et tu es cache de façon
respectueuse, attentive, patiente ou tu
es cache de façon agressive et égotique
? C'est grosse différence évidemment. Tu
sais ce que c'est le ratafia ? Non.
comme ça. Alors pour te résumer
trivialement d'un français à un belge,
c'est de l'agnole qui cogne que tu
coupes avec un peu de jus de raisin de
première pression.
Ah bon ? Ça va être costaud.
Bon, est-ce que tu as un conseil pour
les jeunes générations ? Oui. Quelque
chose d'une bouteille à la mer, quelque
chose d'impérissable qui restera sur les
réseaux avant la prochaine éruption
solaire.
Merci de me donner cette perspective.
Oui, prenez du temps de pour jardiner
votre vie intérieure. Intéressez-vous à
cette question : "Qui je suis ? Qui je
suis vraiment ? La vie m'a voulu là.
Quel est le sens de ma vie ? Où est ma
boussole ? Ma boussole à moi ? Qu'est-ce
qui fait sens ? À quoi j'ai envie de
contribuer ? Qu'est-ce qui me fait très
saillir ? Qui m'ouvre ? Comment est-ce
que je peux décoder les moments où je
vais bien pour comprendre que c'est par
là que j'ai envie de vivre ? C'est ces
valeurs là que je veux reproduire.
Comment est-ce que je peux décoder les
moments où je vis des choses qui me font
chier par l'expression, mais c'est le
langage des jeunes qui m'énerve ou qui
me décourage. Comment je peux décoder
ces moments d'émotion pénible pour
comprendre que c'est plus ça que je veux
vivre et que j'ai envie de pivoter ma
vie vers ce que je veux. Travailler la
connaissance de soi, c'est vraiment un
enjeu de survie de notre humanité.
Qu'est-ce que tu peux dire aux gens qui
disent voilà cette approche peut être
une une approche qualifiée de gourou ?
Ça me fait éclater de rire.
C'est déjà été arrivé ? Non, parce que
tout de suite les personnes voient que
j'invite à l'autonomie. Tout le message
que je viens de dire, c'est l'autonomie.
Arrêtez d'être pris dans un courant de
penser des codes, des modes, le
mainstream, les habitudes, tout le monde
cour dans le même sens et devenez qui
vous êtes quoi. Et acceptez
l'insurrection citoyenne de Pierre Rabi
dont je parlais est là. Dites qui vous
êtes, manifestez-vous, mettez au monde
le meilleur de vous. Thomas dans son
merci. Merci beaucoup. Merci pour
l'accueil.
[Musique]